You’ve been walking for days.
Your body aches, you’re dripping with sweat
from the heat of the sun bearing down overhead.
And yet, you’re wrapped up in layers upon
layers of clothing - even your face is covered,
and you’re wearing thick, black goggles
so that not a single centimeter of your body
is exposed.
Your journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion, or from overheating
due to these multiple layers of clothes.
But dying is better than being exposed.
You saw it happen when your entire team...changed.
The light can’t be trusted.
Not even for a fraction of a second.
It’s been like this for years.
You’ve learned and survived through painful
experience.
Many of those you used to know cannot say
the same.
You’ve been alone for so long.
You might have given up all hope, if it wasn’t
for the distress signal coming from a nearby
SCP Foundation Containment Facility - Site-46.
Any kind of survivors would be better than
nothing, no matter what kind of sorry shape
they were in.
As long as they were still human.
You find your way to an opening in the side
of a mountain, and slide into the cave, hoping
you weren’t spotted.
The whole world is crawling with those things
now.
You can’t let yourself be seen.
As you trudge down the cave towards the entrance,
you see what looks like a huge, black snail-trail
splattered on the ground, leading into the
facility.
You try to avoid it and press on.
You don’t even need a keycard to enter:
The door has been left ajar.
The facility reeks of those things, but you
can’t see any of them.
You just hope they’ve moved on and left
some human survivors in their wake.
The place looks abandoned.
Every step you take echoes through the empty
halls.
When you find that the elevator’s out, you
take the stairs all the way down to Level
B5…
Keter Containment.
Lucky for you, it seems all the cells are
empty now, the horrors that were kept inside
of them have all long since flown the coop.
You keep following that slimy, black trail
until you find an abandoned office.
There are no people here anymore - just a
broken barricade, some empty medicine bottles,
and a bucket that the people inside the office
had apparently been using as a toilet.
You breathe a sigh of disappointment at finding
no one alive here, but you’re at least relieved
to be out of the sun.
You can finally remove your jacket and head-wrap.
With your uncovered eyes, you notice that
a nearby computer terminal is still powered
up.
You sit down at the desk and turn on the monitor.
Because of the Emergency Procedures put into
place in a K-Class scenario like this, safeguards
no longer apply.
You can access all the information you need
- up to and including finding out what actually
happened.
In the dull glow of a nearby emergency light,
you see a dark shape slumping through the
halls in shadow.
You tense up, then exhale as it slithers off
into an adjoining hall.
You’re safe - for now.
The terminal has finally loaded and authenticated
your access.
You’re staring at the file for S.D.
Locke’s Proposal for SCP-001: When Day Breaks.
It’s the only name you can give the apocalypse
your world is currently experiencing.
This is one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be given
the Apollyon containment class - meaning containment
is truly impossible.
SCP-001 is the most dangerous enemy that the
Foundation, and planet earth, has ever faced.
It’s always been a principle of the SCP
Foundation to battle in the dark so that the
civilian world can thrive in the light, but
now, the light has become the enemy.
Anyone exposed to any amount of sunlight for
even the briefest period of time is subjected
to the effects of SCP-001 - and those effects
are beyond horrifying.
The SCP Foundation Administrator released
an urgent memo telling Foundation personnel
to make their way to Site-19 at all costs,
because they need all the help they can get.
Those exposed to SCP-001 in the process are
no longer considered human - their new designation
is SCP-001-A. These new entities are to be
avoided at all costs.
But, in case of emergencies, the Administrator
says it is permitted to cut off parts of your
transformed comrades and eat them to avoid
starvation.
No attempt should be made to kill them, since
you won’t succeed, you’ll just put yourself
at risk.
When the sun changed and became SCP-001, it
instantly affected 6.8 billion innocent people.
The second the visible light touched them
- whether it was from the sun itself or even
reflected off the moon - their bodies liquefied,
melting like candle wax into puddles of living,
gelatinous slime.
This effect isn’t isolated to humans, either:
Any biological entity exposed to sunlight
immediately underwent the same irreversible
melting process into SCP-001-A.
And the horror had only just begun.
People transformed into SCP-001-A will retain
shades of their former intelligence and personality.
They may even try to will their new gooey
mass into a shape resembling their original
form.
However, these individuals will lose their
sense of self if they come into contact with
other instances of SCP-001-A. When they come
together, 001-A instances will bond on a molecular
level, wadding up into horrific, giant blobs
with only one purpose: Integrating more matter
into their bodies.
That’s why they have to be avoided at all
costs.
You continue to search the computer terminal
for answers.
Perhaps there was some kind of contingency
plan put in place for this.
Some way to reverse the effects, or at least
escape the nightmare Earth has become.
Instead, you find a series of attachments
linked to the SCP-001 file, detailing what
seems to be the last days of the people who’d
barricaded themselves in the facility.
Most prominent among these were Researcher
Dr. Logan Igotta, her partner, Ari, a security
officer named Commander Anand, and a few others.
Dr. Igotta had locked herself in the office,
where she recorded her final messages to the
world.
In the first audio log, Dr. Igotta and her
companions seemed afraid but hopeful that
there may be some way out of this situation.
Dr. Igotta reported that most of the workers
at the facility were transformed during the
initial event.
Their melted bodies had fused outside the
facility, and now they were trying to bust
their way back in.
The defenses had held so far though, and they
seemed confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape this
awful situation.
You open the second attachment - an incident
report - and realize that things may not have
been as hopeful as Dr. Igotta let on.
She reported hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside again,
begging for them to come out and experience
the sun with them.
They wanted desperately to add to their ever-growing
biomass.
In order to experiment with what exactly would
happen, they sent out one of their few remaining
D-Classes wearing a full protective suit.
He didn’t last long.
The huge creature grabbed him with tentacles
made of reconstituted flesh.
It began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for mercy.
It was a monster made of dozens of people
and animals.
He could never overpower it.
The second the sun touched his skin, he melted
away, and was absorbed by the great mass holding
him in place.
Guns were ineffective against these SCP-001-A
super-entities.
Fire would do no good.
It seemed that extremely low temperatures
were the only way to slow the immense blobs
down, and even then, not permanently.
There was one ray of light in the darkness:
The Site Director had a secret tunnel underneath
his office, connected to a tram that could
hopefully take them directly to Site 19 without
risk of SCP-001 exposure.
It was a good plan, and by far the best option
they had available to them.
But the best plans often don’t work in practice.
You open the next attachment on the terminal.
This time, it’s a video feed.
You can actually see Dr. Logan Igotta - and
she looks harrowed by what she’s experienced.
As it turns out, while the others, including
her partner Ari, attempted to exit through
the tunnel something had happened.
Dr. Igotta heard Ari’s voice over her radio.
But there was something wrong with it.
It was too low.
Too guttural.
And filled with gurgles.
SCP-001 had gotten to her.
She was changed.
The monster from above had crawled in through
the ceiling.
It had taken them, all of them, and converted
them into something less than human.
Any hope of escape now seemed gone.
Ari told Dr. Igotta that it would be fine.
That it was such a bright, beautiful, sunny
day outside, and she was wasting it locked
up inside that office.
She tormented Dr. Igotta with their shared
memories of picnics in the park on sunny days
in the past.
The monster with Ari’s voice did everything
it could to try to convince Dr. Igotta to
give up and join them, but she wasn’t ready
to go just yet.
You look away from the screen when you hear
a sound in the corner.
You see a dark puddle of some unknown substance,
and then, some skeletal hands rising out of
it.
The hands are pulling themselves out of the
puddle, followed by a skeletal face covered
in matted hair.
You have to stop yourself from screaming,
until a flash from a nearby security light
makes the figure disappear.
It’s a normal puddle again.
Your mind is playing tricks on you.
You open the next attachment, another video,
and see that Dr. Igotta’s condition has
deteriorated.
She looked pale, frantic, and thin.
She was using a knife to draw her own blood
onto a piece of bloodstained parchment covered
in strange symbols.
Igotta ranted about her theory: What if 001
took the minds and bodies of its victims,
but not their souls?
Through performing some kind of arcane blood
ritual, she hoped to at least rescue and keep
the soul of Ari, even if her mind and body
were lost.
You open the next attachment.
It seems that Igotta’s ritual worked, but
not in the way she hoped.
The twisted soul of Ari, driven mad by SCP-001,
had taken over the file.
It begins corrupting the text of the SCP-001
file into crazy ranting about how futile it
is to fight.
It then cut to an even more frightening video
feed: Dr. Igotta in her sleep, tossing and
turning in a makeshift bed in the corner of
her office.
The camera approaches her, in first person,
and lingers over her sleeping body.
An oily, skeletal hand reaches past the camera,
and runs its fingers through Dr. Igotta’s
hair.
It’s the exact same hand you saw reaching
out of that black puddle earlier.
You must have seen Ari’s lingering spirit.
With a lump in your throat, you open the next
attachment and watch the video.
You see Dr. Igotta, now truly broken.
She’d been haunted by Ari’s demonic spirit
for a long time now, and it has clearly taken
its toll.
She is waving around a handgun while she speaks.
She now believes there is only one way to
escape.
But not like this.
She doesn’t want the gun to draw attention
to her body.
She doesn’t want to become part of that
mass, even if she is dead.
She opens a drawer on the desk she’s recording
at and places the gun inside.
Dr. Igotta then apologizes to her loved ones
who are likely long since dead or assimilated,
and turns off the recording for the last time.
In that moment, you realize that there’s
a single drawer in the desk in front of you.
When you reach forward and open it, you see
that the same handgun Dr. Igotta was holding
is laying inside.
You pick it up and study it, weighing up your
options.
Perhaps there truly is no other way out...
Then, you see an update on the file.
One more attachment had been added while you
were studying the gun.
You feel your heart pounding in your chest
as you reach forward and open the attachment.
The text has been changed entirely.
The file on SCP-001 is now a poem - an ode
to the sun, and to ultimate togetherness.
Then a video file spontaneously opens itself
on the screen: It’s a video of you, shot
from behind.
You see those oily, skeletal hands reaching
for you in the dark, just like they did with
Dr. Igotta.
In that moment, you panic and fire the gun
behind you, hoping to scare off the spirit.
Instead, the sound of the gunshots attracts
something far worse.
The immense blob of screaming, melted flesh
charges towards the office.
You try to barricade the door, but it’s
not enough.
The flesh seeps and bursts through, and grabs
you in its meaty tentacles.
You scream and try to escape, but it won’t
save you.
Nothing will save you.
The flesh carries you upstairs, out through
the empty halls, out into the cave.
You can see the light in the distance as the
blob ferries you towards it.
You won’t be alone for much longer.
In fact, you won’t be alone ever again...
It’s tough to know how we might respond
to a true disaster.
What might any of us do when the world turns
upside down, and nothing makes sense anymore?
What if the simple act of stepping outside
into the sunlight became the deadliest thing
in the world?
We’ve delved into this horrifying notion
before with SCP-001, “When Day Breaks”,
or S.D.
Locke’s Proposal.
One of the most nightmarish XK-Class End of
the World Scenarios ever devised.
Mr. Rogers once said that the best thing to
do in times of trouble is “Look to the helpers.”
No matter how dire things become, there will
always be those taking up the difficult work
of putting their community back together.
Firefighters, emergency medical services,
soup kitchens, there are so many different
kinds of helpers out there.
Unfortunately, most of them would be the first
to go once the sun’s rays turned on us all.
The firefighter attempting to put out a blaze
would melt into a puddle of goo.
The EMT running out of an ambulance would
melt the second his feet hit the pavement.
When doom and destruction are everywhere,
who is left to help?
Perhaps someone who has always dreamed of
saving humanity from a great plague, but is
trapped inside with no sunlight in sight.
When the whole world has grown sick, humanity
forever changed into something terrible, we
just might need a Doctor.
Today, we’re looking at what happens when
a dedicated physician meets his greatest challenge
yet.
We’ve discussed SCP-049 many times before.
He is a humanoid entity, standing roughly
1.9 meters in height, resembling a man dressed
in the garb of a Medieval plague doctor.
He is clad in thick dark robes and a ceramic
mask that tapers into a long, sharp beak.
Though it may look like a costume, these adornments
are actually a part of the entity’s body.
SCP-049 wants one thing: to cure humankind
of a mysterious pestilence, the nature of
which has never been entirely clear.
Sadly, his work tends to do more harm than
good.
He can kill with a single touch, and his attempts
to cure human subjects result in malformed
zombies instead.
He carries around a black doctor’s bag capable
of holding an impossible amount of medical
implements, which he uses to perform his work.
Though his actions tend to result in more
harm than good, the Plague Doctor seems to
genuinely care about his patients, their well-being,
and curing them of the illness he believes
to be ravaging their bodies.
049 is singular in his obsession with eradicating
the plague he so often speaks of, and he will
not stop until he has done so.
But what does a doctor do, when there are
no more patients left to treat?
When humanity has been wiped out, and the
Pestilence is gone
for good?
The
Doctor sat in his containment cell, as he
did every other day of his captivity, doing
his best to keep busy.
The scientists of the SCP Foundation were
small-minded, they did not comprehend the
gravity of his work, the necessity of ridding
the world of the Pestilence.
He forgave them for their ignorance, for they
did not know what they were doing.
Instead, he kept his mind on the goal, the
duty he had as a physician and a man of the
sciences.
Just as many scientists had done in the past
when their work was unappreciated, Copernicus
was persecuted for his model of the universe
and his knowledge that the earth revolved
around the sun, Jonas Salk for his controversial
invention of the polio vaccine that saved
countless lives, SCP-049 would be remembered
fondly by history for his contributions.
Even if his contemporaries did not understand
his vision.
And so, in spite of the suspicion and doubt
that surrounded him at this Foundation that
should have been all for groundbreaking research,
the Doctor carried on with his work.
He sat on the floor of the cell, his bag open
next to him.
From its endless interior, he withdrew syringes,
bottles of viscous liquids, tissue samples
suspended in jars, and a stainless steel table
upon which he could place it all.
Today, he would perform a new round of tests
on samples he had been able to extract from
previous patients before he was thrown into
this unjust imprisonment.
These doctors, men he had once viewed as colleagues,
had not brought him a new test subject in
quite some time.
A guard had muttered something about it being
“too costly” to keep “wasting perfectly
good cows” on him.
Simpletons, fools, luddites beating their
fists against their own chests in the face
of true progress.
Their small minds were of no concern to him.
The Doctor placed his tools on his work table
and began to take out the samples.
An ear, a piece of skin taken from the bottom
of a foot, a section of a liver, and, most
exciting of all: the frontal lobe of a human
brain.
Indeed, it would be a fruitful day of investigation
into the mysteries of The Great Dying.
He was just pulling a scalpel from his bag
when his concentration was suddenly interrupted
by the sound of a blaring siren.
He set his tools down and looked up.
That sound…it signified trouble at the facility.
But surely it would be over soon, once the
issue had been dealt with.
Outside his cell, he could hear the thundering
footsteps of guards running past, shouting
at one another too quickly for him to understand.
One man stopped to peer into 049’s cell,
making sure he was still contained, most likely.
“My good fellow!”
The Doctor called out, reminding himself to
speak in the King’s English so the man could
understand.
“Would you be so kind as to enlighten me…what
is the trouble?
If anyone has been injured, I would be happy
to offer my assistance…”
The man did not respond, his attention grabbed
by something further down the hall that the
Doctor could not see.
“Wait!”
He cried, but the guard had already disappeared.
The siren continued to blare, assaulting his
senses with its shrill tone.
In the distance, he could hear screams.
Surely, there was a dire situation at hand.
Had that damnable reptile escaped again?
He approached the door to his cell, listening
for further information.
There was no roaring, no sounds of walls crumbling.
There was only that blasted alarm, and screams
of unadulterated fear and agony.
Very curious, and quite troubling.
SCP-049 tried to open the door, knowing that
it was futile.
He had never been able to escape before, why
would that change now?
Still, a scientist must repeat his efforts
in order to gather new data.
So, he thrust his shoulder against the door,
attempting to break it down.
It did not budge.
Instead, an automatic containment measure
was triggered, releasing lavender-scented
gas into the room in an attempt to calm the
Doctor down.
He did love the scent, it reminded him of
gentler times long ago.
He took a deep breath, imagining fields of
purple flowers swaying in a summer breeze.
That was the world he fought for, not the
flawed human beings that opposed him, not
this sterile facility packed with the ignorant.
For now, he would return to the work.
If they did not desire his help, there was
nothing more to be done.
Sometime later, perhaps hours, perhaps days,
he could not be certain when there was no
sunlight to gauge the time by, the alarm fell
silent.
The Doctor stopped his ministrations and listened.
As the alarm had stopped, so too had the screams.
In fact, the whole facility seemed to have
gone completely, eerily silent.
“Hello?”
He called out, but there was no response,
save for a clicking sound.
Now, that was a sound he had heard before.
Normally, it signified the arrival of armed
guards who would strap him into a harness,
knock him out, and take him somewhere else.
It was the sound of the door to his containment
cell unlocking.
But there was no one there.
Could it be…?
Grabbing his faithful bag, SCP-049 cautiously
pushed against the door.
It swung open, revealing a darkened, vacant
hallway.
Gone were the harsh fluorescent lights, the
D-Class personnel mopping blood stains off
the floors, the doctors hurrying by with clipboards
in hand.
Everyone was gone.
From what he could see, at least.
He would have to investigate further in order
to know for sure.
A scientist never assumes until they have
all of the available information, after all.
So, SCP-049 walked the halls of the seemingly
abandoned Foundation site, expecting to be
interrupted at any moment by an adversary
in a white coat who would usher him back to
his prison.
But the interruption never came.
As he rounded the corner past one of the containment
facilities, a familiar voice called out to
him.
“Excuse me!
Please, could you help me?
Open the door!”
049 stopped and peered into the room.
It was the Possessive Mask’s room, SCP-035.
The Doctor opened the door and there it was,
the porcelain mask grinning at him from its
glass case.
Thick black liquid oozed from its eyes and
wide-open mouth.
“Oh wonderful, it’s you!”
The mask gleefully enthused.
“My good man, you gentleman and scholar,
would you please release me from this awful
case?”
049 paused, considering the potential ramifications
of this action.
“No doubt you’ve noticed, things have
changed around here.”
The mask continued.
“The Foundation is different now…the old
rules have gone out the window.”
“Hm, so it would seem.”
The Doctor replied.
“I will not wear you, understood?
I will only release you from your cage.”
“And for that I will be eternally grateful!”
The mask promised.
The Doctor approached the glass case in several
quick strides, and, with one gloved fist,
broke through the glass.
“Thank you, old friend!”
The mask cried out.
“Now, take me with you!”
The Doctor shook his head.
“I have more pressing matters to attend
to at the moment.
If it is true, if they have all gone…Then
this facility is in dire need of a new head
researcher.”
At his words, the mask’s visage changed,
the cheerful smile warping into an exaggerated
frown.
“And you think you’re the man for the
job?
How embarrassing.
How truly…tragic.”
“Bite your tongue!”
The Doctor retorted.
“Ah, but I don’t have one.
Some physician you are!”
The mask taunted.
Unwilling to deal with the porcelain fiend’s
naysaying any longer, the Doctor turned and
swept out of the room.
Now was not the time for such verbal sparring,
he had so much to do.
This whole facility could be his new workshop,
his laboratory, and he would need assistants
to help him manage it.
But who was qualified enough, loyal to the
cause, armed with sharp wit and a body free
of Pestilence?
As he made his way through the pitch black
halls, he felt something nudge his leg.
He glanced down, uncertain what he would find,
and saw a teardrop-shaped orange creature
nudging him affectionately, gazing up at him
with one large unblinking eye.
Next to his other leg, a mustard yellow creature
the same shape and size was rolling toward
him.
“Are you friend or foe?”
The Doctor asked.
The creatures continued to nudge against his
legs, seeming to want something.
Attention, perhaps?
He bent down and patted each creature gently.
They rolled around his feet in circles, making
a delighted babbling sound.
“Ah, companion it is.
Well then, come along.”
As he continued along his path, the little
creatures rolled after him, keeping close
to his heels.
Suddenly, they began to babble loudly, in
a panicked tone, swarming around the front
of his feet as if to stop him.
“Is there a danger here, my ocular friends?”
The Doctor asked.
From the cell up ahead, a voice cried out
in French.
“Help!
Please!
I’m so hungry!”
The Doctor rushed to the door, opening it
to reveal a behemoth of a man with a large,
rounded chin and jaw, and deep-set eyes that
peered down at him.
The man grinned at the Doctor with impossibly
large teeth.
“Thank you, Sir!
I was sure that I would die in there.”
As he stepped out into the light, the Doctor
could see this giant was dressed in a military
uniform.
“Are you a military man?”
The Doctor asked.
“Yes, I was a soldier in the French army
once.”
The giant replied.
“Before I became the greatest detective
the world has ever known.”
The Doctor clapped his hands delightedly,
his eyes glittering from within his mask.
“Intelligence and loyalty, not to mention
strength!
You, my good man, are everything I have been
searching for!
Would you do me the honor of working as my
assistant?
I have a great deal of research to do, and
could make use of a man with your many talents.”
The giant tipped his hat politely to the Doctor.
“It would be my honor, Sir.
You may call me Fernand.”
He reached out for a handshake, but the Doctor
shook his head.
“It would be best if I did not.
But it is a pleasure to make your acquaintance!”
He glanced down at the eye pods, still skittering
about anxiously.
“See, there is nothing to fear here.”
“Unless I don’t find something to eat
soon…”
Fernand quipped.
And so the Doctor continued along his way,
with Fernand and his new pets in tow.
This was an excellent advancement, but he
would need a great deal more help if he was
to effectively run the Foundation.
He recruited two other anomalies with a mind
for scientific research: a small bird with
a deafening voice, and a doctor himself, and
an eloquent sea slug with years of hunting
and adventuring experience.
It was a relief to find fellow intellectuals
here.
As the ever-increasing band of anomalies approached
the basement, Fernand perked up noticeably.
“Something smells…wonderful.
Just beyond this door!”
Fernand opened the door, and led the group
into a treasure trove of corpses.
They had found the Foundation’s morgue.
Rows and rows of drawers filled with test
subjects, and food for Fernand.
It was everything the Doctor could have possibly
wanted.
“My dear Fernand, take as many as you can
carry and follow me to the laboratory!”
The Doctor declared.
“Tally ho!”
Cried the slug.
“Cack!
And how!”
Dr. Spanko added.
The Doctor set up shop in one of the many
expansive on-site labs.
Though the electricity was out, he could still
get a great deal of use out of it.
There was so much more space in here, so many
more resources than his tiny cell had!
Within a matter of hours, he had set up a
row of IVs pumping out his serums into test
subjects, reanimating them into more lab assistants.
The newly revived corpses shambled around
the lab, bringing him bone saws and forceps,
vials and needles of all sizes, as the Doctor
worked harder than he had in years.
The others were less help than he had hoped,
but with so many newly treated patients to
share the workload he hardly noticed.
All of these poor souls, victims of the Pestilence
no doubt, and he had all the time in the world
now to cure them.
Before long, the once-vacant halls of the
Foundation were filled with the slow plodding
footsteps of his patients, dragging their
swollen limbs across the ground, blinking
their milky white eyes at the chaos outside
the windows of the facility.
As 049 was absorbed in his work, the rest
of the escaped anomalies began to realize
that their freedom had come at a cost.
Where there had once been friendly yellow
sunlight beaming down on a lush green world,
there was now an angry red fire in the sky,
and a landscape covered in strange gelatinous
masses, roving and oozing and moaning as one.
They had escaped from their cells, but they
were still trapped.
Their prison had just gotten larger.
The Doctor had not yet noticed this unfortunate
truth, so focused was he on treating the patients
they had recovered from the morgue.
At least, the ones that had not been given
to Fernand to satisfy his mammoth appetite.
However, a week later, the Doctor was horrified
to discover that there were no more corpses
left, no more patients to cure.
He stood in the empty morgue, looking from
drawer to drawer for just one body they had
missed, proof that his work was not over so
soon.
“What’s the matter, Doctor?”
A sardonic voice behind him said.
He turned to find SCP-035, attached to the
face of a mannequin.
“I see you procured a body.”
He noted.
“No thanks to you.”
The mask replied.
“Oh, how sad.
A Doctor with no one to treat.
What will you do now that you have no purpose
in life?
I wonder…”
“There will be more.”
The Doctor insisted.
“There is an entire world out there that
needs my help.”
The mask laughed in disbelief.
“You mean you haven’t noticed?
There is no world left to help.
It’s all gone to hell.
Take a look for yourself.”
The Doctor rushed to an upstairs window and
gazed down at the destruction outside.
The painful red sunlight, the rubble where
there once were buildings, the masses of soft,
gooey matter that aimlessly squelched along
the ground.
“No…”
He put a hand to his beak, shaking his head.
“It can’t be…”
“But it is.”
Said the mask, standing behind him.
Its face was locked in a grin, delighted to
see him suffering so.
“Your life’s mission, gone…just like
that.”
The Doctor’s knees went weak as he tried
to take it all in.
Perhaps the mask was right, he had no purpose
anymore…
But then, Fernand’s voice boomed from below.
“Doctor!
We need your assistance downstairs!
Quickly!”
The Doctor followed his assistant’s cries
and saw what was so urgent: one of the blob
creatures, an entity he knew must have once
been a human being, had found its way inside
the facility.
Fernand stood back from it, afraid to touch
its slimy surface.
But SCP-049 did not see a monster there, oozing
across the floor.
He saw someone who was sick, desperately ill,
and in need of help.
In need of a Doctor.
“Do not be afraid, my friend.”
He sat down his bag, and reached inside, as
his reanimated helpers swarmed around the
blob creature.
“You are not well, but I am going to help
you.”
The Great Dying may have been out of his grasp,
but if the scene outside the window was anything
to go on, there was still a plague raging
across the earth.
And he was going to find
the cure.
It was such a normal morning.
Almost comically uneventful.
For the first time in what felt like forever,
the morning newscasts had very little to say.
They covered fashion week.
Some protests in the capital.
A new health craze sweeping the nation.
A funny viral video of a dog eating a pancake.
The inspirational story of a young boy from
the midwest beating cancer.
A minor political scandal out of Tallahassee,
Florida, that nobody would remember in a week.
A round of interviews with an expert who’d
written a new book about the long-term effects
social media might have on our children.
None of them knew back then that “long term”
was a luxury they couldn’t afford.
People went to work.
To school.
Some took the day off.
Plenty took walks or jogs, deciding to exercise
outside for a change.
After all, it was such a beautiful, sunny
day out.
What a terrible shame it would be to waste
the light indoors.
People were sleepwalking.
So placidly, blissfully unaware of what was
rattling down the tracks towards them.
It was an uncharacteristically slow day down
at Site-19.
There hadn’t been any containment breaches
in over a week.
A couple of new anomalies had been brought
into containment, one safe-class and one Euclid,
but neither were the kind that was likely
to bring the SCP Foundation any trouble.
Right now, the biggest threat facing their
employees seemed to be boredom, and they’d
definitely take that over any other members
of their rogues gallery.
Dr. Bright poured himself a mug of nice, hot
coffee, and decided to watch some TV in the
break room, just to pass the time.
The President of the United States was giving
a press conference on the White House lawn,
surrounded by microphones.
It was really nothing special.
Just the same inane babble about how he was
going to fix the deficit, and with inflation
on the rise, we’d all need to work on being
more fiscally responsible.
The immortal Foundation researcher sipped
his coffee.
These normal, boring problems felt like the
perfect escape from the insanity he needed
to deal with every day at the Foundation.
The President was saying something about the
importance of families, and about farmers
being the nation’s real backbone, when something
happened.
There was an odd shift in the quality of the
light.
Dr. Bright barely registered it - Maybe it
was something to do with the cameras.
However, things started to get stranger: The
President’s speech began to slur, as though
he’d just been pumped with enough morphine
to take down an elephant.
But it wasn’t just that - He was sweating
buckets, too.
Wet patches expanded all over his suit and
perspiration was dripping off his skin.
Dr. Bright was in suspense - Was he about
to watch the president have a stroke, live
on air?
Would he be called in to replace him yet again?
But no, the situation unfolding was far, far
worse.
The president of the united states slumped
forward over his podium while the reporting
corps screamed.
His face sloughed off his skull like melting
wax, the president’s words slurring off
into infinity.
It was the worst a US president had looked
on film since SCP-1981.
Dr. Bright dropped his coffee cup.
It tumbled and shattered on the ground below.
The camera fell as the operator screamed:
It pointed down into the crowd, where the
reporters were shrieking in pain and terror,
steam coming off of their bodies with the
sudden, intense climb in heat.
They were melting.
All of them were melting before his very eyes,
broadcast out to how many people?
It would be the mother of all containment
nightmares.
Little did Dr. Bright know, that wasn’t
even the half of the true horrors unfolding.
Alarms went off across every containment site
in the world.
Any SCP Foundation employees unlucky enough
to be standing outside at the time were lost
in the rapidly unfolding horrors.
They screamed as the sun cleaved their atoms
apart, reducing them into semi-liquid states
without the mercy of death.
People lucky to be just out of the sun could
only watch as those less fortunate disintegrated
across the ground in unholy shrieking puddles.
Never had such a normal day been thrown into
such terrifying chaos in so little time.
Billions of voices cried out at once as the
sun changed in the sky up above them.
Since the dawn of humanity, it had given us
everything.
Light to bask in, warmth to keep us safe,
and the life of the plants and animals that
kept us fed.
It had been worshipped as a god by countless
cultures over thousands of years.
One great mother to all of humanity.
And now, that mother was drowning us in the
bathtub - And perhaps the most frightening
part of all, it was for seemingly no reason.
No reason at all.
The SCP Foundation was forced to now break
their silence forever.
The masquerade, the veil, it melted along
with so much of humanity.
They took over every communications channel
in the world and did what they could to inform
people on how to get out of harm’s way.
Stay inside.
Wrap yourself in sun-shielding clothing and
only move at night.
Air travel is preferable, if possible.
If you can, make your way to one of the SCP
Foundation’s secure sites, their only chance
of preserving humanity and figuring out how
to reverse this new nightmare.
Now more than ever, the SCP Foundation would
be humanity’s only hope.
Until, of course, there was another terrifying
twist in the tail.
While those who were melted into piles of
living flesh sludge were sadly assumed to
be lost, even the Foundation didn’t expect
the transformed humans to become a threat
in and of themselves.
Just as their bodies were melted, so were
their minds.
They became slaves, cultists of the glowing
tyrant hanging up above.
Some would coagulate into huge, fleshy masses,
horrifying threats that would seek out victims,
overpower them, and drag them out into the
light to be absorbed and transformed.
Even those hiding inside Foundation containment
centers weren’t safe.
These behemoths of melted flesh would find
their way in, using their many twisted voices
to slowly break the minds of their victims,
then gather them up with great flesh tendrils
and yank them out to their doom. Little by
little, the numbers of humanity dwindled.
It looked like we had a bright future ahead
of us - And in this particular context, that’s
far from a good thing.
Survivors, for whatever time they have left,
would forever remember this waking nightmare.
The Foundation dubbed it SCP-001, to reflect
its ultimacy, but to everyone else, it had
a different name: When Day Breaks.
In a world where anything but darkness will
kill you, is there anywhere left on earth
that’s truly safe from the horrors of SCP-001?
Five months into the never-ending horror of
the solar singularity, Alice spooned herself
a bowl full of warm, Swedish meatballs.
Delicious.
She was part of an investigative detail from
a nearby community, deep within the bowels
of the only truly safe place for human beings
on planet earth: SCP-3008, also known as the
Infinite Ikea.
No sun has ever shone in there.
Only the lights, which fizz and flicker far
above.
Everyone inside thinks of it as a prison - Little
do they know, what’s left of humanity out
there would kill to be inside this sanctuary.
Alice had a team of ten with her.
Their mission was simple: Continue the mapping
effort of the area surrounding their community,
and collect rations for the rest of the camp.
It was dangerous work, especially as night
drew close, but there were certain rewards.
When they reached a feeding station, they
were able to enjoy fresher food than anyone
else.
All they needed to do was wager their lives
for it.
To Alice, it seemed like a fair trade.
Her lieutenant, Darcy, kept watch to the north.
He and several others wielded makeshift spears
made from curtain rods and clubs fashioned
from bedposts.
Knives, scavenged from the kitchen section,
hung from their belts in makeshift holsters.
During the day, they were little more than
a precaution.
At night, it could mean the difference between
life and death.
Speaking of, Darcy kept a close watch on a
member of staff.
It was a lanky, faceless monster in that garish
uniform, with a bulbous, oversized head, and
long arms, hanging slack like pulled taffy,
dragging its knuckles along the ground as
it stumbled along.
Darcy thought it darkly funny, how stupid
they could look in the daytime.
Like crash test dummies rejected from the
assembly line.
Bear stood close by.
He never gave any of them his real name, so
they took to calling him Bear, because he
was big, hairy, and would probably tear you
to shreds if you got on his bad side.
He wielded the largest club of all - A customized
creation, with sharp objects sticking out
of it on all sides.
It cleaved the heads of many staff members
off of their bodies.
Bear seemed to relish the task of putting
those monsters down.
For him, it was easy and fun.
That’s why he was an essential asset on
these missions: A berserker.
Most of the grunts shoveled as much food as
they could carry in Ikea-brand tupperware
and coolers.
The more they gathered, the longer it would
take for them to be forced out beyond the
safe walls of the haven they’d built inside
this Swedish, flat-pack hell.
They all made do with what they had in here.
It was all they could really do.
Two members of the team were unaccounted for:
Cyril and Joseph, what passed for reconnaissance
experts down here.
They seemed to have an innate sense of direction,
as though they were somehow in tune with the
Ikea itself.
They would be sent out on scouting missions.
Searching for resources, food, other survivors,
and most prized of all: Potential escape routes.
It was a dream, a fantasy, that someday one
of them would find the exit, and lead the
rest of them to salvation through it.
Alice had been trapped in the Infinite Ikea
for six years, going on seven now.
She had long since given up on dreams of escape.
All they could do was accept their situation,
get used to it, and just try to survive under
these circumstances.
But those circumstances were about to change.
Everyone looked up when they heard panicked
breathing.
It was Cyril.
Just Cyril.
The party clutched their weapons just that
little bit tighter, unsure of what had happened.
Their rules were clear: Scouting duos must
never, ever separate, under any circumstances.
Getting lost in the store, and being isolated
when the lights went out, would be a death
sentence.
So if Cyril was returning alone, frightened,
tears streaking down his face, then something
truly awful had happened.
He told Alice and the rest of the group that
something had attacked him and Joseph.
When Alice told him that was impossible, that
the Staff wouldn’t show active aggression
until lights out unless someone attacked them
first, Cyril shook his head and let out a
heaving sob.
He told them that the creature that attacked
them wasn’t a member of the Staff.
It was something else entirely.
Something he’d never seen inside the Ikea
before.
A true monster.
Whatever this creature was, it’d moved around
a corner incredibly fast.
It spoke in a way that was almost human, but
something was off about it.
Something that sent a chill down Cyril’s
spine, just thinking about it.
He recalled that the creature was large and
blob-like.
Flesh-colored, with long, grasping tendrils
that whipped and flailed unnaturally.
These tendrils had wrapped around and grasped
Joseph.
He hadn’t been quick enough.
The two of them were too shocked by the sight
of it to react in time, and then, it was already
too late.
It grabbed Joseph and yanked him off into
an adjoining aisle.
Cyril still remembered his haunting screams
getting quieter and quieter as he moved further
out of sight.
On some level, everyone hoped that Cyril was
lying.
It was preferable to believe that he himself
had snapped and murdered Joseph for some unknown
reason as opposed to some new, stronger, and
even more dangerous creature that was now
inside the Ikea.
Was this some kind of upgrade?
As they acclimated to the environment, adapted,
gotten better at surviving here, had the Ikea,
in turn, created deadlier countermeasures
to destroy them all?
Just when you thought you had a handle on
things…
But if Cyril was telling the truth, and there
was some kind of creature lurking in the store
- or potentially more than just one - then
they could be in danger just standing here.
They gathered up the group, along with any
supplies worth taking, and set off back to
their community.
They would need to deliver the bad news so
they could potentially prepare for the worst.
It was just one of the many communities housed
within SCP-3008.
Many have theorized over the years that the
Infinite Ikea acts as a kind of nexus point
for Ikeas all across the multiverse, accounting
for the truly insane number of people who
have gone missing without a trace into the
building over the years.
There were children who had been born in the
Ikea, raised in the Ikea, known nothing but
the Ikea.
Nobody knew an exact number for sure, but
it was more than possible that the population
of a small country resided within its walls.
Sometimes, communities would fracture and
fall apart.
Occasionally due to a lack of resources or
infighting.
Other times, due to an overwhelming attack
from the Staff that physically destroyed the
settlement, often leaving many of its members
dead in the process.
Those who weren’t picked off while wandering
the store in the following days would likely
integrate into other nearby communities as
refugees.
Life was cruel in the Infinite Ikea.
By the time Alice and her party returned to
their community, it was almost lights out.
They spoke to the community leaders and informed
them of Joseph’s tragic disappearance, as
well as this awful new creature that Cyril
claimed had taken him.
They thought it best not to inform the rest
of the community tonight - It might hurt their
focus and cause unnecessary panic.
Alice agreed to join the watch that night.
She could feel something wrong in the air.
Even more so than usual, there was something
terrible in this anomalous Ikea…
Alice stood atop the furniture wall with several
others rangers.
As the lights flickered off, the distinctive
calls sounded across the store from the activated
Staff members: “The store is now closed,
please exit the building.”
It was almost soothing in its familiarity,
compared to the frightening thoughts that
Cyril had left swimming through her mind.
The Staff she could handle.
It was at least the devil she knew, and there
were worse beasts than the devil out there.
She knew it in her bones.
They killed a few Staff members that happened
to wander towards the community and begin
beating their deformed fists against the walls.
All standard procedure.
But as Alice’s eyes adjusted to the darkness,
she saw a huge shape in the distance.
It looked like a mountain that breathed.
A huge, wobbling mass of flesh, moving impossibly
fast for a “creature” of its size.
It was so much vaster than the creature that
Cyril had described earlier.
Was this a different one, or had it simply
gotten bigger?
Either way, it was coming straight towards
them.
The community came alive in sudden panic.
Every able-bodied adult grabbed their weapons
and prepared for the fight of their lives
behind the wall.
Whatever this monster was, they needed to
kill it as quickly as possible, before it
destroyed everything they built.
Sadly for everyone inside the community, this
was one fight that none of them were prepared
for.
The beast crashed into the furniture wall,
crushing it inwards.
People struck at the monster’s immense and
terrible flesh with their weapons, making
awful wet slaps, but seeming to cause no lasting
impact.
It just kept rolling in, grasping everyone
it could with its long, sinewy tendrils.
But the horrors were only just beginning.
With the wall destroyed, the Staff began to
pour in, chanting in monstrous unison.
“The store is now closed, please exit the
building.”
It was a massacre, perhaps one of the worst
that the inside of the Infinite Ikea had ever
seen.
While the community battled the giant flesh
beast, the forces of the Staff swarmed and
overwhelmed them.
Darcy was tangled in the nightmarish tentacles
of the beast.
Bear was surrounded by a truly insurmountable
number of Staff members, each one balling
their terrible fists and beating him to death.
Somewhere, Cyril screamed, though his scream
was soon cut short.
Alice watched in horror as everything she’d
known was destroyed.
Alice realized that her friends were dead
and her community was in ruins.
She grabbed her spear and did the only thing
she could: She ran.
She ran from the lost cause that had once
been her life, tears running down her cheeks.
What had even happened?
What the hell had that great monster been?
The Ikea’s trump card?
She ran aimlessly for as long as she could,
then walked, and eventually limped.
She went on for hours, getting lost, deeper
and deeper into unknown territory.
She’d stop when she was dead.
Why not?
She had little left to live for.
But like the holy grail, when she eventually,
truly gave up, and stopped looking for salvation,
it found its way to her.
As she turned a corner around a mysterious
aisle, she saw something that she hadn’t
seen in years: Glass double-doors.
She stifled a sob.
Could it be?
The way out of here, after all this time?
And it was.
The world.
Escape.
She’d lost everything, but regained this.
Outside, dawn was breaking.
After years, the great, red sun.
It was the most beautiful thing she’d ever
seen in her life.
She took a deep breath, smiled, and stepped
into the light…
It had been one month since the end of the
world.
30 long days since Stella had watched her
husband dissolve in front of her, one minute
mowing the lawn like it was any other lazy
afternoon, and the next collapsing into a
useless pile of flesh and jelly.
The end didn’t come like she always thought
it would, with hellfire raining down and pale
riders galloping across the land on horseback.
It began in the kitchen with her humming a
song to herself, mixing up a pitcher of lemonade
before she rejoined her family in the sunshine.
Then they were gone, lost forever when the
sun turned wrong.
She didn’t even have time to grieve them
properly before the threat turned on her,
as the creatures that had once been her husband,
her son, and her daughter swarmed the door,
slamming their new bodies against the wood
with wet slaps, calling out to her in warped
voices begging her to step back outside.
She covered her ears and wept for hours until
she had no tears left to cry.
It didn’t take long for Stella to figure
out that, whatever had happened to her family,
it was happening all over the world.
The small town she had known and loved had
transformed into a hellscape, a maze of monsters
and deadly light.
She retreated underground, to old mine shafts
and tunnels, left abandoned decades ago when
the local coal trade had dried up.
There, she quickly discovered that she wasn’t
the only one with that idea.
There were others, survivors who had managed
to make their way down into the dark, away
from the horrors above.
There weren’t many, and she could never
get too attached to the ones she did meet
in case they too were lost to the sun, but
as the days wore on in the tunnels she found
herself forming a small group of stragglers.
Not quite a family, but something that could
be one day, and definitely much better than
going it alone.
There was Stella, of course, using her background
as an elementary school teacher to keep everyone
on track and working together.
Then there was Brian, a former volunteer firefighter
whose training and skills with an axe came
in handy more than once.
There was Trina, a teenage girl who had been
babysitting when everything went to hell,
who had a knack for evading the flesh monsters
and making supply runs.
And then there was Doris, former military
nurse, and current de facto team medic, sharp
and capable in spite of being in her late
70s.
They were brave people, brilliant, and refused
to give up.
Others came and went, spare survivors they
picked up as they navigated their way, raiding
the ruins of grocery stores and hospitals,
but they always wound up leaving again.
Or, worse, something would go wrong and the
sunlight would claim another victim.
But the four of them stayed together, stronger
with their combined skills, willpower, and
ability to sleep in shifts and keep an eye
out for trouble.
After some time in the tunnels, the group
had come across a massive abandoned facility.
None of them could determine where it came
from, or what organization might have run
it, but it appeared to have been some kind
of research lab.
It was isolated, cut off from outside influences
better than any of their previous hideouts
had been.
Whoever had once worked here had cleared out
- or been taken out - in a hurry, but in their
place, they had left behind rations, medical
equipment, emergency generators, and clean
drinking water.
There were enough supplies to keep the group
going for months, if they rationed carefully.
And so, they settled in.
The abandoned research facility, whatever
it once was, became their makeshift home.
This unexpected sanctuary was cut off from
the rest of the world.
Clinical, cold, lonely, but a safe place for
them to rest their heads.
Now, it had been a month since this all began.
Stella shook her head at this realization,
the passage of time feeling almost meaningless
at this point.
What did a month even mean anymore?
What was a day when she couldn’t even see
the sun rise and set?
As she sat there, warming herself by the side
of a foraged space heater, she thought about
missing the stars, the moon, the promise of
the cosmos.
A time when the vast, open sky was an invitation
to dream, instead of something to hide from.
That time was gone now.
There was nothing to do but mourn it and carry
on.
If not for her, then for the others.
They had all found ways to keep busy in this
new place.
Trina took to exploring the empty halls, the
laboratories filled with strange equipment,
the small rooms that looked like prison cells
or police interrogation rooms.
She had cooked up some theory about it being
a government facility, like something out
of an old episode of The X Files.
Brian had found an on-site library, filled
with history books and scientific texts.
There was enough to read in there, he said,
that by the time he was finished he would
have the equivalent of several doctorate degrees.
Doris had taken initial stock of all of the
medical supplies available at the site, gauze,
disinfectant, vials upon vials of medications
she had never even heard of, and had categorized
them all neatly.
Now, she spent her hours mostly sitting with
Stella, telling her stories about whatever
she felt like.
Her time overseas, her late husband, their
children, decades-old neighborhood gossip.
It felt good to talk, no matter what it was
about.
It felt human.
They all had their ways of keeping a grip
on their own humanity.
It had almost gotten boring, holed up in the
facility without the constant threat of danger
pressing in from all sides.
Boring, but peaceful.
Stella could feel herself starting to nod
off, her eyelids sagging, her dinner of canned
beans sitting heavy in her stomach.
Next to her, Doris had already begun to softly
snore.
Soon, sleep would come for her too, and bring
with it dreams, memories of the life that
was gone forever, the world as she had once
known it.
The dreams were tough, but waking up from
them was even tougher.
Still, she had to rest.
She could only fight it for so long.
She could almost hear her husband’s voice,
when…
“Hey, Stella?
You might want to see this.”
Brian was there, suddenly, his words breaking
through the haze in her mind.
His tone was severe, and she knew that sleep
would have to wait.
She followed him down the hall for a while,
before he stopped and turned her attention
to a section of damaged wall.
It was rusted and corroded, black and grey
with massive cracks in the solid material.
It looked like it had been slowly disintegrated
over time by an incredibly strong acid.
It was off-putting to look at, giving off
the distinct sense that something bad had
happened.
But a lot of bad things had happened in the
past month.
“I don’t really understand what I’m
looking at,” Stella said, and Brian grabbed
her by the shoulders, commanding her attention.
“This wasn’t here yesterday.
Hell, it wasn’t here a few hours ago.”
He gestured to the damage.
“It just happened.
And whatever is responsible?
Is probably still here.”
A chill ran down Stella’s spine.
It seemed impossible for this kind of structural
damage to happen over the course of a few
hours.
She could see twisted steel rebar, drips of
melted metal that had trickled onto the floor.
As she leaned in for a closer look, she gagged.
There was an overpowering stench of rot and
decay.
It didn’t take long for her to spot the
source: a thick, black mucus covered the hole
in the wall, slick and slimy and giving off
the putrid smell.
It wasn’t like the material that made up
the flesh creatures outside, it was something
else entirely.
Something she had never seen before.
She reached out a hand to touch it, but quickly
caught herself.
Whatever this stuff was, it was bad news.
If it could do that to a solid wall, she didn’t
even want to think about what it could do
to flesh and bone.
“What do we do?”
She asked.
“Inspect the area, make sure it’s safe.
See if it’s some kind of toxic waste leak,
or…”
He didn’t finish the thought.
He didn’t have to.
They needed to find out if this damage came
from something living, something that could
be hiding in the building with them and waiting
for the chance to strike.
When they returned to the main room, Doris
was awake and Trina was there waiting for
them.
They agreed to split into pairs and search
the facility, looking for any additional damage,
strange black fluid, or signs of foul play
of any kind.
Trina and Brian went one way, while Doris
and Stella went the other, each person armed
with a flashlight and a weapon of some kind.
An axe, a bat, a knife.
Stella had found a loaded pistol when they
first arrived, one that she hoped she would
never have to use.
Now, she carried it with her.
Just in case.
Stella and Doris walked together for an hour,
keeping an eye out for anything suspicious.
They didn’t find anything notable, really.
There were some bits of rust they hadn’t
seen before, an occasional black puddle pooling
on the floor, but nothing like the scene Brian
had found.
As they walked in silence, Stella felt herself
begin to relax.
Maybe the worst was over, maybe a pipe had
broken somewhere and broken down a bit of
the wall, but nothing else would really come
of it.
Then, from the other side of the building,
there came a high-pitched scream.
She knew that voice immediately.
Trina, screaming bloody murder, and Brian
bellowing something.
She grabbed Doris by the arm, and the two
ran in the direction of the sound.
As they got closer, they could hear other
sounds in addition to Trina and Brian’s
yells.
Loud cracking like something solid coming
apart, bits of rubble falling to the ground,
and the wet dripping sound of something thick
hitting the floor.
As the two rounded the corner to see what
was happening, to help their friends, Stella
froze in shock.
She had seen some harrowing things since that
fateful sunny day.
She almost thought she had become desensitized
to horror, that there was nothing left in
the world that could phase her.
But this moment proved her wrong.
There was so much to take in, and so little
time.
Brian was swinging his axe wildly at the floor,
chopping at it helplessly in an attempt to
break it apart.
It quickly became obvious why.
Trina was sinking into the floor, not through
a hole into the basement below but into the
floor itself.
It rippled and melted around her, changing
from a solid surface to a thick pool of black
sludge.
She flailed and struggled, grasping at the
ground around her, at Brian’s arm, anything
to yank herself free.
But she wouldn’t budge, she continued to
sink.
No…she wasn’t just sinking.
She was being pulled.
Stella felt her legs begin to work again,
and she rushed to Trina’s side, grabbing
hold of her arms with all the strength she
had.
All the while, Trina screamed in a mix of
desperation, terror, and pain.
Brian continued his assault on the ground,
as if he could cut her free from the floor,
and Doris moved to help Stella.
She grabbed ahold of Trina’s waist but stopped
suddenly.
There, at the place where her body vanished
into the floor, Trina was beginning to fall
apart.
Whatever had turned the floor into a portal,
whatever had rotted away at the walls, it
was taking its toll on her body too.
The flesh falling away from the bone, the
muscles liquifying, and everything being corrupted
by that same black mucus.
If they pulled any harder, Trina would be
ripped in two, her chest, arms, and head on
the surface while her legs, stomach, and most
of her vital organs were lost.
There was no way to save her.
Stella saw it when Doris did, and the two
shared a long, sad look.
Trina was here with them, still struggling
for her life, but she was already gone.
As if it felt their hopelessness, the force
pulling on Trina from below then gave the
horrifying yank they were praying to not have
to witness, and she was swallowed up by the
ground.
All that remained was a sticky black smear,
a large crack in the floor, and three survivors
where there had just been four.
None of the remaining three slept a wink that
night.
Brian paced back and forth, holding his axe.
Doris went over their supplies again, looking
for anything that could be used to treat the
effects of the corrosive black fluid.
And Stella ran over their potential options
again and again.
They could stay, and hope that the thing that
took Trina never came back.
Or they could leave and face the possibility
of succumbing to the sun or the influence
of the creatures that once were people.
She recalled dimly an old adage: The devil
you know beats the devil you don’t.
Maybe that was true, maybe it would be better
to take their chances with the outside rather
than stay and be hunted.
But she thought of her husband and children
again, watching them melt away onto the grass,
and she shuddered.
There were no good options here, but she couldn’t
risk going out like that.
They would stay.
Whatever had taken Trina, there were three
of them, and only one of it.
Besides, maybe it had already gotten what
it wanted, and now it would move on.
She didn’t know when she fell asleep, only
that when she eventually woke up, she was
alone.
Brian and Doris were nowhere to be found.
She called out their names as her heart leaped
into her throat.
For a moment, she feared the very worst.
But then, Brian answered her.
He had been patrolling, looking for signs
of trouble, but he was fine.
She asked if Doris was with him, and he went
pale.
He told Stella that Doris had gone to an on-site
bathroom to get cleaned up hours ago, before
he left.
She should have been back by then.
Without another thought, they took off toward
the bathroom and saw their worst fear realized.
The door to the room was gone, rotted away,
and Doris was gone with it.
She had been taken before she even had the
chance to scream.
They stood there, taking in the reality of
what had happened with silent shock.
Then, a sound from behind caused them to turn
around.
It was a raspy, hollowed-out sound, like air
forced from a dying man’s lungs.
A dry, empty, evil chuckle from an inhuman
throat.
There, they saw the creature that had stolen
their friends.
From a distance, Stella could have confused
it for a man, a very old, very sick man, but
still human.
As it shuffled closer, however, that illusion
was shattered.
Its eyes were black voids, its skin grey and
putrefied, its mouth a gaping toothless maw
of shriveled black gums.
And it was laughing at them.
Like it was enjoying itself.
There was the smell again, that overpowering
reek of all things foul.
Stella drew her pistol and fired several shots.
She didn’t have the best aim, especially
not when her hands were shaking with fear,
but one of the bullets found its target and
hit the creature in the cheek.
It hissed, not in pain, but a perverse amusement,
as the lead tore a hole through its flesh
like wet paper.
Globs of black blood spattered everywhere,
spreading the rot wherever they landed.
To her side, she heard Brian cry out in pain.
When she turned, he was clutching his right
eye.
Some of the liquid had hit him there, and
it was already taking effect.
Stella’s stomach turned as she saw something
white slide down the side of Brian’s face,
his eye melting out of its socket.
The skin around it followed suit, softening
like putty and dribbling away from the bloody
muscle underneath.
Brian collapsed to the floor, as the creature
continued to advance on them, laughing louder
and louder.
It knew that bullets couldn’t kill it.
Knew that there was nowhere to run.
Stella grabbed ahold of Brian’s arms, prepared
to carry her fallen friend to safety, but
he stopped her.
“I’m done for,” he said, quietly.
“If you try to carry me, you are too.”
She shook her head, unwilling to leave him
behind, and he touched her cheek, forcing
a smile on his decaying face.
“I didn’t think I’d make it this far.
I wouldn’t have without you.
So run, save yourself.”
She could hear the resignation in his voice
and knew that he would not let her save him.
“I’ll hold him off as long as I can,”
Brian promised, and, with tears in her eyes,
Stella turned and ran as fast as she could.
As her feet pounded the ground, blood rushing
in her ears, she could hear Brian screaming
and cursing at the creature until his voice
quickly faded to a wet gurgle, and then, silence.
Stella sat in the center of the room that
she and the others had once shared, clutching
her scavenged pistol in her hands.
Every creak, every errant sound made her jump.
It could be anywhere.
Come from anywhere.
She had escaped from so much already, survived
more than anyone was ever meant to.
Had lost her love, her friends, her home…she
wouldn’t lose herself too.
She held her breath as she heard it, clear
in the darkness: Drip.
Drip.
Her grip on the weapon tightened, and she
readied herself.
If she had to go down, she might as well go
down swinging.
The Old Man, whether he was a man, a monster,
or death itself, wouldn’t be taking her
anywhere…not without a fight.
We’d been so cautious, keeping quiet, covering
up, only moving at night, but sometimes, despite
all your best efforts, you just get unlucky.
We made our way through what we thought was
an abandoned street, littered with broken-down
cars, when those...
Things had slithered out and ambushed us.
Kaspar, who was always the most trigger happy
of us, panicked and opened fire with his scavenged
submachine gun on the largest of the creatures.
Big mistake.
It didn’t slow the monster down, and only
seemed to attract more.
It’d be blob city before sunrise now.
But poor Kaspar wouldn’t make it that long.
Fleshy tendrils wrapped around his limbs and
pulled him into the terrible mass of one of
the creatures.
It started reshaping around him, enveloping
him as he screamed, until the tide of flesh
coursing down his throat silenced him.
The whole time, the monster just kept gibbering
madness in a warped voice.
“Become one, yes, let our cells bond and
our minds coagulate in the glorious shimmering
light.
We will all be one in daylight, pretty flower,
yes, yes, yes...”
And then there were four.
Me, Ellen, Darcy, and Jones.
There had been more of us once, but in this
war of attrition, we always seemed to be the
ones who had to lose.
And if we didn’t get away from these monsters
quickly, then there wouldn’t be any of us
left soon enough.
We ran, ducking and weaving around the cars
as the blobs got closer.
There were so many of them, all howling and
ranting, zealots for the only cause their
melted excuses for minds could understand
anymore.
Occasionally, we fired back, hoping to slow
them down a little - But it never worked.
The guns, if anything, were a psychological
support mechanism, and something to scare
off other survivors who were even more desperate
than us.
When it came to the blobs, especially the
big ones, the only things you could do were
run and hope.
And hope’s in short supply these days.
No matter how fast we ran, the blobs kept
catching up, and they didn’t seem to get
tired.
Knowing we couldn’t outrun them, we ran
up to one of the abandoned cars and crouched
behind them, breathing raggedly.
This whole stupid mission, in hopes of eventually
reaching safety, a good night’s sleep behind
solid walls, and some people who actually
know what the Hell is going on.
I drew my sidearm out of my pocket.
Even if I didn’t make it out of here, I
wouldn’t turn into one of those monsters.
Pulling back the hammer, I muttered a quiet
prayer.
If there’s a God out there, he had a hell
of a lot to answer for right now.
I looked to Ellen, Darcy, and Jones, and they
all had the same idea.
It was a pleasure to know them all, after
everything that’d happened.
We heard the blobs getting closer, their lunatic
whispers growing in volume and intensity,
as they always did before they claimed one
of us.
I breathed a sigh, ready to accept my fate,
knowing what I needed to do.
It all seemed to be over.
Until He appeared.
I looked up and spotted a strange man approaching.
He was dressed in an old-fashioned hessian
toga, His hair and beard frosty white.
I couldn’t identify His age or race, but
those factors seemed secondary to the fact
His eyes were glowing brilliant white, as
if exuding pure energy.
He raised a hand, the same glowing aura of
pure white energy emanating off of it.
I’d seen so many things that terrified me
in the past six months.
But this...
This was the first time I’d experienced
something I could call “Awe.”
He walked towards us with a stillness and
confidence and said “You look like you could
use a hand.”
Where were you when day broke?
Whoever’s left, they remember.
I was in a supermarket with my wife and two
kids, just another normal day.
I was worrying about bills, taxes, and whatever
we were going to have for dinner that night.
If the Devil exists, I’d sell my soul to
the nasty red creep to get those worries back.
Lucky for us, we were in the back half of
the store, lit entirely by artificial light.
The people checking out their groceries down
front, right in front of the building’s
huge, glass facade, they were the first to
go down.
All these terrible drowned screams.
First, the exact kind of shrieks you’d expect
from somebody starting to melt.
Then, the gurgling, like a backed-up drain,
as their mouth and throat melted around the
sound, choking it.
Those were the first minutes of Hell on Earth.
I’ve never been the smartest man.
I was a roofer, back when things made sense.
Never went to college, never been much for
reading, but I had intuition, and I credit
that with surviving this long.
My dad was in the service.
Two tours in ‘Nam.
He always told me when I was a kid, the guys
who didn’t make it back, they panicked.
Because that’s what the enemy wants you
to do.
They hope, when everything hits the fan, you’ll
break formation, forget the plan, and all
start scurrying in different directions like
rats, just hoping you’ll be the one who
finds a crack and gets out.
That’s when they get you.
When you panic, you’re giving up the birth
rite of reason and letting the animal take
over.
“And animals, son, are easier to kill.”
When the sun went bad that day, plenty of
people in that store started running.
They didn’t know what they were running
from, or where they were running to.
They just wanted to put some distance between
themselves and the screaming.
Every man for himself.
I’d love to tell you all those people are
dead now, but in actuality, they were in for
a far worse fate.
They ran out of the safety and cover of the
store, putting themselves at the mercy of
the light.
Even as they melted, they kept running.
They were blobs, slithering away, not even
knowing that the thing they were running from
had already gotten them.
It all happened so fast, but I can remember
every single detail.
You can judge me if you like.
I don’t care anymore.
If I could have spoken reason to those terrified
people that day, hand on my heart, I would
have.
But one of man’s greatest design flaws is
that God made fear the master of reason.
Nothing I could’ve said that day would’ve
changed anything.
The only ones I could hope to save were my
family, so that’s exactly what I did.
We grabbed what we could, stayed away from
windows, and made our way to the nearest supply
closet.
We were in there for hours, and we didn’t
come out until things were actually quiet.
Which, coincidentally, happened to be at night.
When we stepped outside of the store, we saw
the carnage that must’ve unfolded over the
past few hours.
Windows smashed.
Cars driven into storefronts and abandoned.
Slithering blobs of former-people on the ground.
In the space of a few hours, the world had
truly and irrevocably changed.
No matter what happened, even if we survived,
we knew there would never be a “normal”
as we’d known it before ever again.
The same message was playing on every TV,
radio, and computer.
A logo I didn’t quite recognize, along with
an overlay that read, “An Important Message
from the SCP Foundation.”
It explained, in an eternally looping, robotic
voice, that they were superseding the control
of all world governments to protect humanity
from this new and terrifying threat.
In short, the sun had turned against us.
In some scenarios, survival is a curse.
In those early days and weeks, you wouldn’t
believe the number of times I started to envy
the dead.
People who’d been wiped off the mortal coil
by diseases and car crashes and random acts
of violence in the days before Day Broke,
they had no idea how good they had it.
Little by little, in this terrible new world,
death became a kind of luxury.
Because melting under the fiery gaze of the
sun?
That wasn’t death.
Not even close.
They seemed harmless at first.
Tragic, pitiful, really.
The voices on the TV even told us that, to
avoid starvation, we could eat small parts
of the melted.
But, over time, the situation evolved.
I don’t know when it started, or why, but
the blobs that had once been people started
coagulating.
They joined up, started turning into bigger
creatures, all with one mind, always screaming
and talking madness in a collage of stolen
voices.
These monsters existed for one purpose, and
one purpose only: Finding the people who were
still normal and dragging them out into the
light to join them.
They roamed the world during the night, hunting,
seeking.
And given night was the only time we could
ever safely move, this created problems for
all of us.
We lost so many to those terrible monsters.
Including my wife and both my kids.
See what I mean about survival sometimes being
a curse?
Especially when you’ve got people to miss.
I wish they were dead, all three of them,
but I still hear them - their voices added
to the chorus of a house-sized flesh monster.
But I lived on, if you can call this living.
I met with others, like Kaspar, Ellen, Darcy,
and Jones.
All of them had lost people.
You hadn’t lived this long if you hadn’t
lost people.
We did all we could to keep surviving against
the odds.
We spent our days in basements and abandoned
stores, and our nights dodging the flesh creatures
and foraging for food.
We eked out each day, taking every breath
as it came.
We didn’t hope for anything.
Until one day, we heard that the people at
the SCP Foundation might know how to reverse
all this.
They needed all the people and help they could
get at one of their bases, around twenty miles
away from us.
It’d only be a couple nights walk to get
there, we figured, so why not help out the
cause?
Safety in numbers, after all - And, truth
be told, we’d missed people.
After days of hiding and nights of traveling,
we were ambushed, but you already know about
that part.
We lost Kaspar to one of those monsters and
got cornered behind an abandoned car.
However, as the blobs got closer and closer,
that mysterious stranger with the glowing
eyes appeared.
He didn’t walk like the rest of us.
He was bold, confident, His back straight
as a dancer’s.
Like He feared nothing.
Like nothing here could hurt Him.
Suddenly, I felt a rumbling behind me.
The car was rattling.
I feared for a second that the blobs were
crawling over it to get us, but when I turned,
I saw the opposite was happening.
The car was rising off of the ground, free-floating.
Myself and the other survivors stared in astonishment
as the stranger simply flicked His wrist.
The floating car was thrown with tremendous
force at the largest of the advancing blobs.
It hit the beast so hard that the top of it
simply splattered off, freezing what was left
in place.
Even the other blobs paused, seemingly astonished.
We all turned to the stranger, still standing
firm.
“Stand behind me if you wish to live,”
He said.
There was something both passionate and commanding
about His voice.
It was impossible to hear Him and not heed
His words.
All of us stood up and ran behind the stranger,
as He lifted both hands.
Debris climbed into the air.
Cars, rocks, broken glass.
The blobs were beginning to coagulate again,
but this time, the stranger wasn’t going
to let them get the upper hand again.
With a slight nod, everything He’d raised
flew at the blobs with the force of a machine
gun.
They were decimated.
The bigger ones, cut apart.
The smaller one fleeing to avoid the onslaught.
After months of running from these monsters,
I don’t think any sight could have been
more satisfying.
When the creatures were gone, the stranger
just gave a quiet sigh.
He turned to us and asked if we were okay.
The answer was, essentially, “About as much
as we can be.”
He told us that we’d be safe as long as
we stuck with Him, and after that display,
we had every reason to believe Him.
We followed the stranger down the long, dark
road.
He always walked in the middle, fearless,
making no attempt to hide.
When we asked Him His name, He told us that
He goes by many names, but for the sake of
simplicity, we could call Him Matthew.
We thanked Matthew for saving us, and He gave
a sad sort of smile, and told us that He only
wished He could have done more.
There was something so strange about Matthew,
even beyond the fact He apparently had superpowers.
I’d never met the man before and I’d be
willing to bet my right hand on that, and
yet, it felt like I’d known Him my entire
life.
He was so different, and yet, so incredibly
familiar.
We told Him we were on our way to a nearby
SCP Foundation facility, where we were told
we’d find safe haven.
We asked him if he knew where to find it.
Matthew told us that, in fact, He’d lived
in that very site for decades, a visitor,
just dropping in.
He’d had a very stressful job before, and
felt like taking a sabbatical while things
ran themselves for once.
“Evidently, my help was more necessary than
I imagined,” He said.
Occasionally, as we walked, we’d see blobs
watching us from crevices and dark alleys
on the side of the road.
They seemed to watch, but, for some reason,
didn’t approach.
It was the most remarkable thing.
“Don’t worry,” He told us.
“I’m putting up invisible shields.
None of them can approach us as long as I
maintain my focus.”
Of course, we’d all heard stories of remarkable
and terrifying things wandering the wasteland
we used to call planet earth.
You couldn’t run into other survivors and
groups without hearing whispers about the
things lurking out there.
Some had told of a giant, monstrous reptile
that had destroyed an entire survivor settlement
in a mall out in Nevada.
Others told that one of those SCP Sites was
haunted.
People spoke about a ghostly man who looked
like a rotten corpse, who could walk through
walls and drag people to Hell.
But the things Matthew was capable of seemed
to be a whole other level.
I asked Him what He was, and He told me, “Just
a humble craftsman, my son.
I enjoy creating, though admittedly, my creations
seem to have gotten away from me these days.”
His evasion was less funny than He seemed
to think it was.
I pressed on, asking Him what exactly he’s
capable of.
He shrugged, and answered that he could do
almost anything if he really put his mind
to it.
I asked, “So...
Ultimate power?”
This gave Him a chuckle.
He shook His head, and said, “Let me tell
you a story.
A man comes upon a maze cut into a corn field,
and decides he wants to try his luck.
He spends hours getting to the center of the
maze, and there, he finds the Devil waiting
for him.
The Devil says, ‘Welcome to my domain.
Your soul is now forfeit, unless you can complete
my challenge and win it back.’
Of course, the man agreed.
The Devil said, ‘I can see everything, do
everything, and be everything.
I know every inch of the universe and can
produce anything from thin air.
If you want to keep your soul, name one thing
I can’t do.”
Curious, I asked, “What did the man say?”
Matthew smiled and said, “Get lost.”
And for the first time in those long, dark
months, I actually laughed, and it was at
such a stupid, corny dad joke.
It’s a strange world we live in.
“Point is,” Matthew continued.
“There is no ‘Ultimate Power.’
Some things are denied even to God, especially
when he chooses to walk as a man on the Earth
he created.”
We kept walking for hours.
Matthew assured us that we would get there
in time, as the rest of us got ever more anxious
about the thought of the rising sun.
He said he’d seen so many sunrises now that
he could time them to the second.
In the meantime, we should enjoy getting to
stretch our legs a little.
Even now, the city could be beautiful at night.
When He led us all the way to what seemed
like an abandoned chemical plant, I could
feel my heart sink.
All this time, all this work, to find more
people, to find safety, only to see that this
place was abandoned, too.
Matthew smiled, and said, “That’s just
what they want you to think.”
He snapped his fingers and the ground around
us began to rumble.
The concrete shifted seamlessly and an entrance
opened up below.
Heavy bulkheads shifted, revealing a sleek,
chrome hallway down into the ground.
We were astonished.
Matthew gestured down into the hall and we
descended.
Matthew followed us, the entrance closing
behind him.
“I’m just warning you,” He said, “This
may come as a bit of a shock.”
We ventured deeper, passing through different
automated security checkpoints as cameras
gazed down from above.
Eventually, we found ourselves in what seemed
to be a central chamber.
It was a hive of activity.
People in normal civilians clothes.
Guards in tactical gear.
Scientists in lab coats.
Tears filled my eyes, it was the most people
I’d seen in one place in months.
A man in a lab coat wearing an extravagant
medallion approached.
He was making notes on a clipboard.
“Another batch of survivors.
Good work, 343,” the man said.
Matthew smiled and nodded.
“No problem, Jack.
Always happy to help.”
The man with the medallion - Jack, presumably
- turned to me.
“I imagine you’ve come a long way,”
he said.
I nodded.
“You have no idea.”
Another day, another failed attempt at death.
If SCP-682 had anything even resembling a
sense of humor, he might ask for it to be
printed on a motivational poster and stuck
to the side of his containment chamber, where
he eternally melts and regrows at the mercy
of high-concentration acid.
They’d just cross-tested him with Able.
Again.
Unlike some of the others he’d been forced
to face, that tattooed swordsman seemingly
wasn’t intelligent enough to fear.
He’d always come back, just as stupid and
violent.
This encounter had left the Hard to Destroy
Reptile at thirty percent of his previous
body mass, bloody and bashed.
He’d survived the encounter.
He always survived.
They brought what was left of him back to
his cell in a forklift.
A blasted forklift!
How could it even be more humiliating?
As his eyes started to grow back in his head,
he could swear he even saw one of the technicians
laughing at him.
His name tag read, “Agent Nigel Kelly.”
Noted. 682 would specifically hunt down and
kill him the next time he breached.
Of course, every single day, he plotted revenge
against the human race - along with everything
else.
But the sum they owed in pain, blood, and
despair could never be repaid in full.
After all, every single one of them
- except Dr. Bright -
could only really die once.
They’d brought 682 to the precipice a thousand
times, only for his own body to cheat him,
and deprive him of the sweet release of death.
And if the Foundation had their way, it would
be done a thousand times more, and they wouldn’t
even stop there.
682 couldn’t even imagine the number of
containment breaches it would take to deal
a blow even comparable to the one he had faced.
All he could do was dream.
Dream of a reckoning that would turn the tables.
Something that would plunge humanity into
the state of constant pain and terror that
had been all he’d ever known since these
fumbling sadists in white coats had locked
him up here.
What a beautiful day that would be...
Little did SCP-682 know, that very day was
about to break.
Miles and miles away from the facility where
SCP-682 was kept - after all, orders from
the O5 Council have hard mandates on the minimum
distances between people and a site holding
a monster as volatile as 682 - parents watched
their children laughing and frolicking in
an idyllic playground.
Some squealed with glee as they descended
the slide.
Some of the more ambitious little tykes tried
to go over the bar on the swings.
Others waited in line for some delicious soft
serve at a parked Ice Cream truck.
One mother bought an ice cream cone and walked
over to a nearby bench, where she began to
enjoy her delicious frozen treat.
It was a remarkably hot day out and a little
ice cream was the perfect addition to her
relaxation while her kids were occupied.
You could see the distant air wobbling in
the heat.
Already, her ice cream was starting to melt,
white rivulets dribbling down the sides of
the cone and onto her hands.
Suddenly, almost imperceptibly, the quality
of the light shifted.
The kind of thing you’d dismiss as a trick
of the eyes and forget just as quickly, were
it not for the catastrophic effects that were
about to unfold.
As the woman leaned forward to lick her melting
ice cream, something dripped onto her skirt.
But, as she looked down, she slowly realized
that what dripped onto her wasn’t the pure
white of her ice cream: It was the exact same
tone as her skin.
She felt a terrible burning sensation all
through her body.
The most horrible, debilitating pain she’d
ever experienced, like every cell in her body
was screaming and trying to make a break for
it.
She turned to the other parents sitting near
the playground.
They were screaming too.
Each collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness, different parts of their body falling
at different speeds as they transitioned through
states of matter.
When they hit the ground, they were taking
on a liquid state.
Screaming, worthless, boneless blobs.
The woman even saw her own arm wilting like
a time lapse video of a dying flower.
She dripped and sluiced through the cracks
in the bench, until nothing recognizably human
was left.
Only a soggy ice cream cone sitting uneaten.
In an instant, billions of screams rang out
over planet earth.
Day had broken.
Things would never, ever be the same again,
as almost half of humanity instantaneously
took on a liquid state.
Needless to say, with the most dangerous and
far-reaching anomalous incident in human history
suddenly breaking out without any kind of
warning, the SCP Foundation was incredibly
busy.
This would take some unprecedented action.
The members of the O5 Council who weren’t
melted during the initial blast convened over
secure video link while sequestering themselves
underground.
In what amounted to multiple human lifetimes
of some of the most high-pressure choices
imaginable, they made the most difficult decision
since the very beginning of the SCP Foundation.
In the service of all mankind, they would
now break the masquerade.
The SCP Foundation would, at long last, step
out of the shadows to save the rest of humanity
from the tyranny of the light.
Broadcasts went out all over the globe.
Every TV screen, every livestream, every radio
broadcast was commandeered.
They gave instructions based on the scattered
intel they had.
For some reason, the sun had turned against
them.
Exposure would lead to any biological creatures
melting away into sentient piles of flesh-colored
sludge.
People would remain indoors and away from
any light sources.
All windows must remain covered.
Travel only at night, and even then, heavily
covered with protective gear.
There can only be one objective for whoever
is left: Make your way to the nearest SCP
Foundation containment facility and seek refuge
inside.
If anyone could figure out the answer to this
terrifying existential riddle, it would be
the SCP Foundation.
Anyone who was exposed should be considered
lost.
While, as always, the SCP Foundation did all
they could to project a sense of control over
the situation, on the inside, it was pandemonium.
Somehow, despite everything, this event had
taken all of them by surprise.
How could anyone have predicted that the cradle
of our solar system’s delicate living balance
would suddenly become a meat grinder?
A huge number of Foundation operatives were
wiped out in the initial exposure.
Global communication infrastructure had been
devastated.
It was pure chaos.
And to SCP-682, as another evil tactician
once put it, chaos was a ladder.
From the inside of his acid tank, 682 could
sense the fear and pain suddenly exuding from
his surrounding environment.
It was greater than ever before.
What was happening out there?
This was no average containment breach.
Something was really, really happening out
there.
682 began to adapt and finely attune its hearing,
until it could pick up chatter from outside.
“Maybe we can convert some of the D-Class
barracks into serviceable bunkers for the
refugees?
It’s not like we’re prepared for this
kind of capacity!”
“Oh god, oh god, we’ve lost Site 7, Site
10, Site 23, Site 40, Site 52...”
“Death toll looks to be in the billions.
Well, we don’t know if they’re dead, technically.
But they’re sure as hell not human anymore...”
“This is the Big One.
This is it.
XK-Class.
Even 2000 is unaccounted for.
Is O5 crazy that they think we fight the freaking
sun!?”
Needless to say, 682’s curiosity was piqued.
Anything that could light a fire under the
Foundation like this was something he could
enjoy.
And, with his impressively strategic intellect,
he intuited that a time of great strife for
the Foundation would be the perfect time to
breach containment.
Cause whenever there’s violence, fear, and
chaos on a mass scale, SCP-682 will be there,
causing it.
682 began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful alkaline
substance.
Little by little, the alkaline neutralized
the acid surrounding him, turning it into
little more than plain water.
He then converted his internal systems to
have extreme endothermic rather than exothermic
properties, causing his surrounding temperature
to drop rapidly, until all the water in the
tank completely froze around him.
The ice expanded beyond the limit of the containment
unit, busting the rivets of the metal frame
and shattering the reinforced glass.
With this goal achieved, 682 raised his internal
temperatures to incredible highs, melting
the ice around him.
Once again, he was free, and ready for some
good, old-fashioned carnage and mayhem.
Perhaps he could get a better handle on this
strange new situation, too.
It was all rather exciting.
Just a girl with goals huh?
SCP Foundation personnel were already running
around like ants trying desperately to avoid
the caustic laser beam of the magnifying glass.
You can only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through the
wall, Kool-Aid man style, and began to ruthlessly
massacre everyone around him.
Just one of those days, you know?
The typical order during a 682 containment
breach is to dispatch all available units
to get him back under control.
The issue with this particular containment
breach was that, given the human population
was very rapidly being melted and they were
the only ones who could potentially save the
rest, they didn’t really have any available
units to pursue and recontain 682.
For once, he really wasn’t a priority, and
that meant terrible things for whoever he
ran into.
682 slaughtered his way through any researchers
or guards who dared to get in his way.
Disgusting creatures, really.
Better off dead.
He clawed and bit and tore and crushed with
almost childlike glee, leaving great piles
of bodies in his wake.
All the while, he was pondering the things
he heard those Foundation drones saying.
Something about the sun and an XK-Class scenario.
Interesting. 682 also observed that any apertures
that could potentially allow light into the
facility had also been shuttered.
Perhaps they weren’t overreacting this time,
like they always did with him.
Maybe they were dealing with some kind of
phenomenon that would now cast this wretched
world and those who lived in it into the void.
Wouldn’t that be a fitting karmic fate for
them all.
Still, 682’s bloodlust didn’t outweigh
his logic.
He needed to know more about this situation
before proceeding.
And in this, maybe he could kill two Foundation
birds with one stone...
Elsewhere in the building, alarms blared,
the air was suffused with panicked voices
and frequent screams.
Nobody knew what was going on, not really.
They’d only gotten details here and there,
and the details they’d received were terrifying.
All their families and loved ones outside...
Probably gone.
So many of the people and so much of the world
they’d been fighting for, risking it all
for, had disappeared in an instant.
Carried to hell on a ray of sunshine.
Why were they still here?
Was this horror not truly uncontainable?
These questions were swimming through the
mind of Agent Nigel Kelly as he stood alone
in his office, almost catatonic.
He’d had friends and family on the outside,
all likely reduced to those horrible fleshy
blobs.
He was alone in the world.
Risking his life for nothing.
How could this get any worse?
His mind kept repeating that question again
and again and again.
And the universe gave him an answer, in the
form of a deep, reptilian voice saying, “Found
you...” into his ear from behind.
He turned with a shriek to see the terrible
eyes of SCP-682 staring into his own.
Before he could try to flee or reach for a
weapon that he knew would only mildly annoy
the already furious beast, 682 reached out
with a massive, clawed hand and grabbed him
by the torso, lifting him up into the air.
The creature was gripping so tight he could
feel his ribs starting to crack.
“You laughed at me, Agent Kelly,” the
monster hissed.
“Am I funny to you?
Do I seem like the type to tell jokes?
Do you feel like laughing now?”
Agent Kelly begged and pleaded for his life,
fighting for his next breath from the crushing
squeeze of the creature’s terrible hand.
682 roared at him to be silent and ordered
him to tell him everything he knew about the
situation going on outside.
If the information was useful, 682 might show
his thought-to-be-non-existent magnanimous
side, and let Agent Kelly live.
Of course, Agent Kelly didn’t fancy his
chances, but what other choice did he have?
He told 682 that the higher-ups were calling
this SCP-001: When Day Breaks.
The sun had gone rogue somehow, and being
in contact with any kind of sunlight would
now cause people to instantaneously melt into
horrifying, living sludge.
And it wasn’t just people.
The condition also affected anomalies, and
interestingly, it appeared to negate all previous
anomalous effects - so 682’s adaptational
ability may not even save it if it was exposed.
He’d told 682 everything he knew.
“Are you going to let me live?”
Agent Kelly asked, struggling to breathe.
682’s terrible maw twisted into what might
have been a smile.
“Oh, Agent Kelly,” he said, with unsettling
joy.
“That was just a joke.
Didn’t you find that one very funny?”
A terrible scream emanated from the Agent’s
office.
If one good thing could be said for what happened
to Agent Kelly that day, at least he didn’t
live long enough to see the ravages of the
terrible sun first hand.
682 began to formulate a plan.
He took Agent Kelly’s wristwatch and integrated
it into his body, so he’d have a permanent
internal clock.
It was the middle of summer, so the sun would
have reliably set at 9 PM and would likely
begin its rise at around 5 AM.
It would be relatively easy to avoid the sun,
all things considered.
For lack of a more eloquent way to put it,
when it comes to adapting to new threats,
SCP-682 is simply built different.
After slaughtering a few other members of
SCP Foundation staff for the road - Hey, it’s
not like anyone was fit to stop him - 682
began enacting the next phase of his plan.
His body grew a thick, smooth carapace, and
his front set of limbs began to grow, his
muscles bulging and his claws growing, the
tips turning into sharp, flat scoops.
With sudden and tremendous force, 682 began
boring his way into the ground.
Tunneling, clawing through concrete and dirt
with absolute ease.
Normally, the SCP Foundation would have deployed
high-tech seismic sensors and the kind of
tunnel-boring machines that Elon Musk could
only dream of to intercept and recapture him.
But during the endless horrors of the breaking
day, he had carte blanche to escape and live
it up in the ruins of this rapidly dying world.
Eventually, 682 had bored his way into a roomy
sewer pipe, the perfect place to wait out
a few hours.
Up above, so many millions screamed, either
in fear or in agony.
There had been some new developments that
the SCP Foundation had been yet to account
for.
While they knew that those melted by the rogue
sun were technically alive and trapped in
a permanent state of suffering, what the Foundation
didn’t know was that these former humans
were incredibly dangerous in their own right.
The sun hadn’t just irreparably warped their
bodies, it had also irreparably warped their
minds.
It has enslaved them.
Made them zealots.
Acolytes.
They developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant, fleshy masses, driven by the single-minded
purpose of finding victims and dragging them
out into the light, where they too could be
converted into these terrible fleshy creatures
and add to the masses.
These were the rogue sun’s boots on the
ground, metaphorically speaking.
And now, they were the Foundation’s greatest
challenge in getting a handle on this situation
again.
Before, it was just encouraging people to
avoid the sun.
Now, the sun was actively trying to increase
its exposure.
But 682, who was having a relaxing evening
not being melted for once down in the sewers,
couldn’t care less.
He was having the most calming few hours he’d
had in years.
He waited, checking the time, making sure
that it would be dark before he began tunneling
back up to the surface world.
He surfaced in the middle of a city, miles
away from the Foundation facility he’d spend
so many decades being tortured in.
He tasted the cool night air and observed
the desolation that had been wrought all around
him.
Buildings were on fire.
Cars were crashed and overturned.
The ground was cracked.
Garbled SCP Foundation Public Service Announcements
played to nobody in the broken display windows
of electronic stores.
Giant wads of human flesh roamed, slithering
around, searching for new victims.
One noticed 682 and began to approach him,
gibbering madly in a chorus of strange voices.
The Hard to Destroy Reptile wasted no time
in attacking.
It tore apart most of the hideous blob and
began hungrily devouring the chunks.
The form may have been different, but it still
tasted like human flesh, and SCP-682 savored
every single bite.
It would be so simple.
These blobs of idiotic flesh were so easy
to kill, and there would be so many terrified
humans in this devastated world, hiding away
in dark places, holding out the hope that
maybe they could reach the safety of a Foundation
facility.
682 chuckled at the very thought.
Foolish hope would drown in an endless well
of black, caustic despair.
He would find them.
He would rest underground in the day and then
hunt them in the dark.
They would all die screaming, bloodying his
claws and fangs.
Nothing and nobody would stop him.
He looked out over this strange new world
and laughed a little louder.
It was just...
Delightful.
Lewis Jackson sat with all his fellow students
in the dingy, underground lecture hall, listening
to a rickety old professor with a voice like
chloroform rattling off dry facts about economics.
Above him, a projector older than any of the
students in the room covered the back wall
in a poorly-designed PowerPoint presentation,
limping from slide to slide.
It was 9 AM on a thoroughly unremarkable Monday.
Half the class was hungover, the other was
just terminally bored.
Lewis hoped none of this would come up on
the final, because this morning, he had no
intention of listening.
Instead, he was typing out a message under
the desk with a big, stupid grin on his face.
“Professor Harbison is going off about the
free market again.
Save me.”
Send.
The message’s recipient, Jenny Park, started
typing.
Lewis’ crush on Jenny was the college’s
worst kept secret.
Ever since they met during O-Week, he’d
been infatuated with her.
They shared a few classes, but little by little,
they started hanging out more in their free
time.
Study sessions, grabbing lunch together, going
to the movies.
They’d become fast friends, but Lewis was
hoping they could be something more - and
he hoped, deep down, Jenny was thinking the
same thing.
He received a text.
“We can hang out in the quad after if it
makes him easier to endure.
We’ll grab burgers, my treat.”
With a winking emoji.
Lewis felt like a dork to admit it, even to
himself, but this message made his heart race.
They were doing winking emojis now?
Maybe today wouldn’t be such a drag after
all.
Any day that he got to hang out with Jenny
couldn’t be all bad.
All of this news was so exciting to him, he
didn’t notice that something strange was
sweeping over the lecture hall.
While the professor droned on, even the most
studious members of the class were suddenly
checking their phones, faces alight with expressions
of confusion, then concern, then worry.
Something was happening.
Something big.
Professor Harbison fell silent as a new sound
rose to prominence - Muffled at first but
getting rapidly louder, just outside the lecture
hall.
It was screaming.
Terrible screams of fear and pain.
People started to rise out of their seats.
What was going on out there?
Nobody had heard gunshots or an explosion.
The ground wasn’t rumbling under their feet,
and if a hurricane or a tornado was tearing
its way across the campus, they would have
heard it.
Suddenly, the main doors to the lecture hall
burst open, and a terrified student rushed
through.
Lewis recognized him: It was Tommy Lansdale,
a History Major that Lewis had hung out with
a few times at campus parties.
He was a chill guy, the kind of person who
took everything on the chin and let life’s
troubles just roll off his back.
That’s why it was so strange to see his
whole body shaking, and his face a red mess
of tears.
“You can’t go out there!” he screamed.
“There’s something wrong with the light.”
Concern was starting to give way to panic.
Tommy turned and shoved the bolt into place
on the door, eliminating the potential exit.
The only other way out was a fire escape down
by the stage.
His heavy breathing and choked sobs weren’t
doing much to calm anyone down.
Lewis checked his phone again.
Jenny was still typing.
Tommy kept repeating, “Something wrong with
the light, something wrong with the light,
something wrong with the light...”
The other students were starting to approach
him, all with a sense of guarded caution,
given they still didn’t understand the situation
well enough to know for sure that Tommy wasn’t
the dangerous one here.
College could be an extremely stressful place;
it definitely wasn’t unheard of for people
to snap under the pressure and do something
they wouldn’t normally do.
“What’s going on, man?”
Lewis said, walking briskly up to Tommy, worried
about Jenny’s safety if something really
was happening out there.
Tommy raised both hands in a gesture that
seemed halfway between pleading and a threat,
shaking his head frantically.
“Stay back, dude, you don’t wanna go out
there, something terrible is happening!”
Professor Harbison approached, adjusting his
glasses and sneering.
He didn’t take kindly to someone interrupting
his lecture with these ridiculous theatrics.
An institute of learning was no place for
this kind of troublemaker.
“I demand you leave this instant, young
man,” Harbison said.
“If you don’t stop this foolish behavior,
I’ll have you written up.”
Tommy didn’t budge.
He just shook his head emphatically.
“I’m not going anywhere,” he said.
“If you go out there, you’re gonna die.
I’m not letting anyone leave this damn building!”
Before anyone could protest this unwilling
confinement, a terrible sound started to come
from outside.
Not screaming this time, just a voice.
A warped, pained voice that seemed almost
to droop as it spoke, like a voice recorded
on an old reel-to-reel tape recorder that’s
starting to degrade.
“Help me,” it slurred.
“Please, let me in, I feel so sick...”
There was a terrible slopping noise, like
a thick, viscous liquid sluicing closer.
Tommy looked down and screamed.
Flesh-colored slime was slithering in underneath
the door and dripping over the top step of
the gangway.
Tommy stepped back, along with everyone else.
It looked revolting and smelled even worse
- like a mixture of rotten meat and burning
hair.
That terrible drooping voice was still somehow
emanating from the slime.
“Please... Please help me...
Something went wrong...”
Naturally, the other students began to scream
and run.
Whatever that monster was, they needed to
get away from it, quickly.
Only Lewis seemed to be rooted in place, the
terror and impossibility of it all just paralyzing
him.
He could only watch as the flesh-colored blob
creature seeped in under the door.
Everyone else, including Professor Harbison
- who was moving faster than he had in years
- made a mad dash for the fire exit down by
the stage.
Tommy screamed for them to stay inside, but
it was already too late.
People panicked and piled on top of each other
to get out, but the second they did, the worst
of the screaming started.
The most awful, agonized wails you’ve ever
heard, that tapered off in that same drooping
gurgle as the blob slithering in underneath
the door.
It was Lewis’ natural instinct to run down
and help, somehow, but instead, he felt Tommy’s
white-knuckle grip on his shoulder.
“I’m sorry,” Tommy said through sobs.
“It’s too late for them.
There’s nothing you can do.
We just need to stay inside.”
At that moment, Lewis received a text message
from Jenny, it read:
“Lewis, if you’re still okay, you need
to read this and you need to believe me.
Something terrible has happened.
So many people are dead.
Or at least, I think they’re dead, a lot
of them are still screaming.
I think it has something to do with the sun.
Stay out of the light.
I’m in Administration Building C. I’m
safe, for now, but I’m hiding.
Don’t come looking for me until nightfall.
Please let me know if you’re okay.
You can’t trust the sun.”
Lewis felt a wave of relief and terror wash
over him: Jenny was okay, and that was great
news.
But it seemed like this nightmare, whatever
the hell it was, was affecting everyone out
there.
It was a force melting people down and turning
them into monsters.
The screams from outside the door were getting
worse.
All those people who had been, well, people
so recently were something entirely different
now.
And they were in terrible, terrible pain.
Lewis and Tommy ran down to the fire escape
next to the stage and forced it shut, trying
not to look at the tide of liquid flesh that
was roiling in the apparently hostile sun
outside.
They were lost now; Tommy and Lewis didn’t
want them coming back in.
Lewis breathed a rattling sigh and hammered
out a reply to Jenny.
“I’m safe in a lecture hall with Tommy
Lansdale.
We’ll come to you as soon as we can.
Don’t worry, it’s all going to be okay.”
Lewis shoved his phone back into his pocket.
Now isn’t the time to keep checking.
He asked Tommy what he knew.
How had he survived…
Whatever all this was?
Having some kind of knowledge about what they
were dealing with might have given them a
better chance of surviving.
Tommy had just finished up a seminar in a
nearby classroom and was heading over to the
canteen to grab a Reuben while preparing for
his next class.
He was lucky enough to be under a covered
walkway, bathed in the early morning shade,
when something about the sun changed.
It was hard to even describe - A certain shift
in the quality of the light, a kind of shimmer,
almost.
It didn’t affect him, but the people in
the courtyard a few feet away…
He was shuddering as he told the next part
of the story.
He swallowed hard over a lump in his throat,
staring off into the distance with a haunted
look as the memories played over his mind.
Tommy described the people in the courtyard,
the ones out of the shade who were first exposed…
They just started screaming and falling apart.
Losing form.
Melting.
Becoming awful piles of shapeless slop on
the ground.
It was instantaneous, and all it seemed to
take was a fraction of a second of sun exposure
for the whole process to take effect.
Nothing was worth the risk of exposure to
something like that.
Nothing.
But Lewis disagreed.
There was one thing worth risking his life
or the integrity of his body for: Jenny.
They had to get to Administration Building
C as quickly as possible.
And not just because of the new threat raging
outside, but because Building C already had
a certain…
Reputation.
Rumor had it that a number of people had gone
missing in that building back in the 1970s.
Since then, people had experienced strange,
inexplicable things.
Odd chills.
Strange noises.
Creeping feelings of doom in certain areas.
In short, it was the last place Lewis wanted
Jenny to be trapped.
But neither he nor Tommy could help until
night fell, seeing as they wouldn’t be great
rescuers in a semi-liquid state.
They waited for ten torturous hours in that
lecture hall as day turned to night outside.
In that time, they heard so many terrible
bubbling screams out there - Pain trying to
escape a slimy prison.
It was enough to drive you mad with fear.
Both checked the news and their Twitter feeds
on their phones, hoping to find out if there
was any more information on what was happening
out there.
It seemed the worst had come to pass: This
insane phenomenon was unfolding everywhere.
People across the world were suffering under
the transforming rays of the terrible new
sun.
Some group called the “SCP Foundation”
was releasing information about it, telling
people to come towards their buildings at
night for safety.
Lewis committed this fact to memory.
When they’d collected Jenny, they’d head
straight to one of these buildings.
Hopefully someone there could tell them what
the hell was going on here.
Someone out there had to have answers about
all this.
When it got dark outside, Lewis felt his phone
buzz in his pocket as he received another
text from Jenny.
This time, it was:
“Lewis I’m scared.
Please come quickly.
I’m downstairs.”
And with that, Lewis knew it was time to leave.
He and Tommy steeled themselves, and when
they were sure it was dark out, they ventured
forth from the lecture hall and onto the quad.
There, they saw the aftermath of the horrors
that the sun had wrought.
The grass was covered in more huge, flesh-colored
blobs, slithering across the grass like mutant
slugs.
Just the sight of them made Lewis and Tommy
feel nauseous, but they didn’t have time
to stop and take a breather.
If Jenny was in trouble, they needed to get
to Building C, fast.
It looked even more frightening at night:
As one of the oldest buildings on campus,
it could best be described as “dilapidated.”
The facade was less fitting of a university
administrative building and more of a haunted
house.
It occurred to both Lewis and Tommy at that
moment that neither of them had ever actually
been inside this building before, and what
seemed like the end of the world was certainly
an interesting time to start.
Lewis and Tommy entered the building and turned
on the lights in the lobby.
They heard a voice at first, oddly toneless
and robotic, but soon realized it was a video
playing on loop on the computer at the unmanned
reception desk.
It was another message from the SCP Foundation.
“This is a Public Service Announcement from
the SCP Foundation.
We are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital message.
Avoid sunlight at all costs.
Cover your bodies thoroughly.
And follow the instructions on the screen
to reach the nearest operational SCP Foundation
containment site…”
Neither liked the sound of the phrase “Containment
Site”, but they’d worry about the semantics
later.
Jenny had said she’d been hiding “downstairs”,
and there was no sign of her here on the first
floor, so it stood to reason she was on some
kind of basement level.
Strange.
It seemed like all the doors here led up…
Except one.
A door that looked like, until very recently,
it had been bolted to the wall.
“Well…” Lewis said, trying to mask his
fear.
“I guess it’s now or never.”
Tommy opened his mouth to answer, but before
a single word could pass his lips, a huge,
fleshy tendril shot through the front door
of the building and wrapped around his throat.
He managed only a choked gasp as it dragged
him back towards the door.
On the other side of the threshold, a mountain
of flesh eagerly waited.
A gibbering nightmare of half-formed faces
screamed and wailed in the terrible fleshy
form.
It happened so quickly that Lewis couldn’t
even hope to save him.
He was gone, subsumed by the blob, his face
disappearing into the flesh before Lewis could
even scream.
But there was no time to stop and process
the shock.
Another several tendrils were already reaching
for him; he could practically see it happening
in slow motion.
Pulsing.
Grasping for him.
Perhaps it was only his will to see Jenny
again that gave him the strength to do so,
but he dodged the tendrils by a fraction of
an inch and dove towards the door - the same
door he assumed Jenny had escaped into hours
earlier.
He threw open the door and disappeared behind
it, slamming it in place and holding it fast.
He could feel the tendrils smashing up against
it, hammering away.
Lewis heard all those terrible, deranged voices
screaming for him on the other side.
He was holding it for ten solid minutes before
the creature finally gave up and slithered
away.
The second the silence fell, Lewis’ phone
buzzed in his pocket again.
He fished it out and saw another message from
Jenny.
It read:
“Please come.
Afraid.
So dark here, so dark here, so dark here,
so dark here, so dark here…”
And it was at that moment that Lewis began
to take in his new surroundings.
He was standing in a stairwell, one that seemed
much older and more dilapidated than even
the rest of the building.
But most notable of all was the fact that
he had never, ever seen a place so dark.
Impossibly dark.
Not “dark” as in the absence of light,
but dark as an almost physical presence, choking
out the light.
Even with his phone on full power, the light
didn’t penetrate much of the black.
Was Jenny all the way down here?
Lewis was afraid, but he could only imagine
how Jenny was feeling down there in the depths.
He took a deep breath and started descending
down into the darkness, using his phone camera
to light what little of the way was possible.
The deeper he got, the more he started to
feel a strange, intangible dread beginning
to creep in, like an invisible hand compressing
his chest.
As he got deeper, he noticed a sound: Quiet
weeping.
An unmistakably female voice, somewhere down
below.
It sounded too young to be Jenny, but then
again, Lewis had never actually heard her
cry before.
Whatever the case, he needed to get down there
and remedy the situation.
He forged on, further and further into the
dark, even as his terrible sense of dread
increased.
He couldn’t help but notice that no matter
how far down he went, it always sounded like
the crying was the same distance away.
It unnerved him, but Jenny had to be down
there.
She had to be.
And even if he gave up on her, it’s not
like he could just go back up and leave.
There were monsters out there - like the monster
that’d gotten Tommy.
Even down here in the darkness, he was safer
than up there.
Or at least, that’s what he thought.
He felt something strange under his foot and
looked down.
It was an old piece of torn-up orange fabric,
with “D-9884” written on it.
The phone buzzed again.
A new message from Jenny.
This time it read, “I can see you.
Can you see me?”
Lewis looked around.
He couldn’t see anything.
He tried desperately calling Jenny again.
He yelled her name until his voice went hoarse.
No reply.
Just that same soft weeping so far below.
Maybe she was on the flight below him.
She must have been close.
He doubled his speed, vaulting down the stairs
to the next level, when he noticed something
on the ground.
A Smart Phone - One that, over so many study
dates, lunches, and outings to the movies,
he’d learned to recognize.
It was Jenny’s.
He picked it up, studying it, only to see
that it was dead, the screen cracked and the
battery lifeless.
His own phone gave another buzz.
A text from Jenny.
It read, “Look down.”
And, against all rational thought, that’s
exactly what he did.
There was something at the bottom of the stairs.
A strange, pale face, somehow illuminated
in the darkness.
At first, he thought it could have been her,
and ran towards it.
By the time he realized he was wrong, and
he was staring into the blank eyes of a face
without a mouth, inches from his own face,
it was already too late.
Lewis let out a scream, but there was nobody
there to hear him.
But on the bright side, at least he never
would see that sunlight again…
The sun’s gone bad!
People and animals are melting everywhere!
The world is coming to an end and there’s
nothing I can do about it!
Will I be able to find food?
Will I be able to defeat or avoid the horrific
flesh monsters all around me, or the desperate
and hungry survivors left in this terrible
new world?
Keep watching and find out.
Can I survive 100 days in SCP-001 - When Day
Breaks!?
Hey folks, it’s ya boy, Kyle.
You probably know me more for gaming videos
than post-apocalyptic vlogs, but hey, I’m
a versatile guy, and I think I might go insane
from the fear if I don’t talk to somebody
about all this craziness.
If you’re alive and seeing this right now,
well, congratulations, you’re probably doing
a lot better than most people here, if you
can call them “People” now.
But if you’re seeing this a few years in
the future, like, I don’t know, you woke
up from a ten-year coma like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you’re wondering what the
hell happened to Planet Earth…
This video is probably gonna answer a lot
of your questions.
First thing’s first, whatever you do, you’ve
gotta stay away from the sun.
It touches you even for a second, you’re
dead, or worse.
Welcome to Day One of the End of the World.
For all of you who are still in a solid state
of matter, you’re probably wondering how
I’m still alive, too.
Chances are, it’s for the exact same reason
you are: Sheer, dumb luck.
I was down here in my gaming basement when
day broke, just level grinding when my TV
got taken over by those SCP Foundation people,
telling us that the sun’s gone evil for
whatever reason and now we’ve all gotta
stay inside.
Hell, if I was up there making myself a sandwich
or grabbing another can of Mountain Dew, I’d
be a freaking puddle right now.
It’s funny, my mom always told me spending
all day indoors was bad for me.
I’ll have to mention that to her, if she’s
alive…
Okay, okay, back to business.
I’ve been spending the last several hours
just waiting for nightfall outside.
Against all odds, the internet and the power
grid haven’t gone down yet - Guess whatever’s
wrong with the sun only affects people and
animals, not objects.
Thank heaven for small mercies, right?
People on Twitter have been live-posting their
situations out there, sharing advice on how
we might all be able to stay out of the sun
and survive this whole crazy thing.
And hey, unless they’re dead or full of
hot air, maybe those “SCP Foundation”
people know something about what’s going
on here.
If we really can get to their buildings, maybe
we can figure out how to reverse all this
mess.
Maybe.
For now, I’m just gonna focus on staying
alive.
Hopefully night hits soon, I really need
the bathroom…
Hey folks, I’m back, thankfully.
Welcome to Day Five.
We’ve still got electricity, thankfully,
hence why you can still see this.
I haven’t heard anything from my family.
I don’t wanna assume the worst, but…
It’s probably just best not to think about
it.
I’ve been heading up and downstairs to grab
more food at night.
You’re probably wondering, “But Kyle,
why don’t you bring it all downstairs to
save going up altogether?”
To which I’d say, I don’t have a fridge
downstairs, smart-ass.
But I’m starting to realize food is gonna
be a real issue here.
It’s kinda stupid, now I think about it
- In all the zombie movies and TV shows I
used to watch, it was all bullets and baseball
bats.
Killing your way through all those undead
freaks and worrying about the rest later.
Guess they don’t want you to think about
how you’re only ever a couple of weeks away
from starvation, kinda ruins the badass post-apocalypse
power fantasy.
I only have a couple days worth of food left
here, and after that, I’m gonna need to
go out and search for more.
Or I’m gonna need to relocate.
I don’t feel comfortable here anymore, y’know?
Early on, I thought when you got exposed to
the sunlight, it just killed you.
But no, it’s worse.
You keep living, you’re just changed into
one of those…
Things.
These last few days, I’ve looked out the
windows when I’ve come up at night for food.
I see them sometimes, slithering in the yard
or down the street, these things that used
to be people.
I wonder if they’re people that I knew once,
before all this, then I try to shove that
thought out of my mind.
Freaking myself out about all this doesn’t
help, I know that much.
I just keep thinking about how they move,
with this weird kind of… purpose?
Like they’re searching for something, but
what could they be searching for?
I’m just gonna go and get more food.
We’ll speak again soon.
Stay safe, whoever you are.
Okay, okay, I’m alive.
That’s enough, isn’t it?
And if you’re watching this, I assume you’re
alive too.
Congratulations, Welcome to day 27.
Sorry that I haven’t been in contact for
so long.
As you can see, I’m not at home anymore.
You couldn’t pay me to go back there - Ha.
Not that money is worth anything anymore.
A lot’s happened since I last made one of
these, and I wish I could tell you any of
it was good.
Hell, I wish I could forget it all, but the
things I’ve seen and heard…
I don’t think they’re ever gonna leave
my head, no matter what I do.
It started a few days after my last video.
When I ran out of food, just like I knew I
would, I started sneaking out at night to
try to get my hands on whatever was left.
There’d been some looting, but not much.
Most of the perishables had already rotted
away by the time I got there, so when I run
out of canned peaches and mandarins I’ve
got scurvy to look forward to.
But hey, we’ll cross that bridge when we
get to it, right?
I thought about making another entry now and
then, but I always found a reason to put it
off.
It’s remarkable how all your other priorities
fall away when you’re thinking about where
your next meal is coming from, it just kind
of puts everything in perspective.
Of course, during my travels, I saw more of
those freaks slithering around.
Sorry, sorry, I know I shouldn’t call them
that.
It’s kind of a coping mechanism, you know?
It all gets a lot harder when you have to
think of them as…
Ex-people.
That’s another thing all those goofy zombie
shows got wrong: It’s a lot harder to separate
what they were from what they are now, especially
when you know these were your friends, your
neighbors, your…
Well, I can’t avoid talking about it forever,
can I?
I stuffed my backpack with whatever I could
grab and left my home two nights ago.
It wasn’t just because I was going stir
crazy back there, though I admit, that didn’t
exactly help.
It was what happened there.
I’d just come back from a food run, put
most of it in the fridge, then retired back
down into the basement to enjoy a late-night
snack and do a little gaming to keep myself
sane.
I’d been doing everything I could to reverse
my circadian rhythms and sleep during the
day, just so I could be fully operational
during the twelve-hour period that going outside
wouldn’t melt me.
But just like all those stories they told
us when we were kids: There are monsters out
there at night, and they’re looking for
us.
When I first heard the sound, I wondered if
it was something in-game, or maybe dripping
from a leaky pipe.
But no, it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be water.
That’s when I looked at the door and saw
this awful pink slime slithering in underneath
my door.
It was one of those things, those Ex-People,
trying to get in.
That’d be bad enough, but then, it started
talking to me…
“Kyle…
My darling…
Why are you all cooped up down here?
It isn’t healthy.
You ought to come out side, sweetie, get some
sun…”
It was my mom.
Well, it used to be.
Guess she wanted to come over and visit me.
Needless to say, I got out of there, and I’ve
got no intention of going back.
That place is dead to me now.
I don’t ever want to think about that voice
ever again, both her and so…
Not her.
So now, I’m on the move, guess I’ll speak
to you again when I stop.
Stay safe out there.
Hello, again.
Guess I lied when I told you I’d record
another one of these when I stopped, cause
I’ve been on the run for weeks now.
Let’s give it up for Day 43.
If you’ve lived this long, you really ought
to be proud of yourself.
I’ve seen thousands of those slimy Ex-People,
and there are probably millions more out there
- Hell, maybe even billions, if we’re being
honest with ourselves here.
Am I just talking into the void here?
Is there even anyone else out there who’s
human enough to watch this stuff?
Maybe I just need to keep thinking about posterity.
On the off-chance that the world ever gets
better, and we reach some time when children
are born again and all this fades from human
memory, you’ll still have these stupid,
pointless little videos to remember how awful
all this was.
That way, at least I can make myself believe
this all had some kind of point.
So, what’s happened?
With me, not much.
Still moving at night, surviving, hiding in
closets and underground parking complexes
during daylight.
I’m down to my last few cans, so I’m hoping
to hit a supermarket soon.
What a ridiculous way to go: Starving in this
new world, with so many new, interesting ways
to die.
With the Ex-People, things have been a little
more eventful.
There used to be one blob to a person, but
they’ve started…
Joining up?
That’s the best way I can put it.
Things that used to be people and animals
are starting to melt together, getting bigger
and bigger.
They’ve never been aggressive, but I think
it’s best to stay out of their way.
Whatever all this is about, I’m streetwise
enough now to know it can’t be anything
good.
I’ll just keep moving, and I hope you can
do the same, whoever the hell you are.
Hopefully, the next time I check in with you,
it’s with better news than this.
Note to self, in the future, don’t even
dare to think “How could things get any
worse?”
Because if I’ve learned anything since this
whole nightmare started, that is never a rhetorical
question.
Welcome to Day 64.
If you’re still alive and watching this,
I’m so sorry.
So, I’ve got good news and bad news.
I’ll give you the good news first: I’ve
seen people, real, honest to god people, since
the last time I recorded one of these.
And the bad news?
Last time I saw them, they were being dragged
out into the light, kicking and screaming,
in the tendrils of one of those horrible flesh
monsters I was telling you about last time.
They’ve gotten a lot bigger now, and when
I told you they weren’t aggressive, well,
I spoke a little too soon.
I can’t just sleep during the day like I
used to.
These monsters - and that’s what they are
now, they’re monsters, not people anymore
- they patrol, they hunt.
They actively enter buildings, searching for
hiding places, searching for people they can
drag out into the light.
I’ve seen it with my own two eyes - The
second they’re out, they just start melting
and fusing with the mass, making it even bigger,
adding another voice to the chorus.
And I hate myself, cause every time I’ve
seen it happen, all I can think is, “Thank
god that’s not me.”
I wish I could do something to help, to save
them, but that’s not the world we live in.
The second they touch the light, it’s already
over.
I wouldn’t be helping anyone by adding my
flesh to one of those things.
I don’t want them using my body to get other
people.
There’s only one thing I can do now: Keep
moving at night, stay hidden, get away from
population centers.
I’ve realized where I need to go now: I’ve
still got a distant memory of those broadcasts
in the early days of the event.
The SCP Foundation.
I noted down coordinates to the nearest facility
they had on the books - And if I’m honest,
“nearest” is only a relative term, cause
at this rate, it’s gonna take me an eternity
to get there.
But it’ll be worth it in the end, when I
get there.
It’ll all be worth it if I can at least
get some answers, at least know why the world
turned into this Hell.
Those SCP folks seemed better prepared for
this than anyone, so even if they can’t
fix this, they’ve at least got to have answers,
right?
Somebody needs to have answers.
I really want to believe that.
When the sun goes down, I’ll start moving
again.
If you’re watching this, wish me luck.
I don’t have much food left.
I’ll do what I can.
Yeah, I realize I’m not looking great right
now, but trust me, you should see the other
guy.
Welcome to day 86.
Never thought I’d make it this far, but
life’s just full of surprises.
Before you ask - and I mean, why would you
ask?
It’s not like I can hear you - it wasn’t
one of the monsters that did this to me, it
was another person, just like me.
Desperate, hungry, afraid.
The one difference between me and them was
the fact they had a handgun, and I didn’t.
They asked for all the food I had, and when
I wasn’t exactly forthcoming, they decided
to shoot me, and steal the last of my food
while I lay bleeding on the ground.
Well, that’s not entirely fair.
They did leave me with one protein bar, which
I had to cave and eat a couple of days ago.
Since then, I’ve just been foraging what
little food I can from plants along the way
during my nighttime walks.
But it isn’t much, and my wound is giving
me grief.
I sure hope they’ve got doctors at this
SCP Foundation, or otherwise, I may be even
more out of luck than I thought.
Here’s the good news for you, since I know
how much you love that.
I’m not far off of the Foundation site now.
Even in this state, I’m probably only a
couple of weeks away.
I think maybe I can will myself to live that
long, at least.
If I can get some answers just before I die,
then I can die happy.
And sometimes, folks, that’s all you can
ask for.
Final stretch.
Let’s hope I see you again on the other
end.
Stay safe…
I’m here!
The SCP Foundation on Day 100!
But…
I don’t understand.
Where is everybody?
Hello?
Is anybody there?
God damn it, why is nobody here?
I don’t understand.
They were meant to have the answers.
They were meant to know what was going on
here, but they’re all gone too.
It isn’t fair, it isn’t fair.
Is this it?
Is it all just over?
The end of the freaking world as we know it?
It isn’t fair, it isn’t fair, it isn’t
fair…
Wait…
Are those footsteps?
Hello? Yes, hello, I’m over here!
Who’s there?
Oh my god, what the hell is that thing!?
No, no, get away from me, oh god!
“Disgusting…”
Dr. Jack Bright was having the second-worst
day of his life, and things weren’t about
to get better.
He ran down the main hall of Site-19, medallion
jangling against his chest.
All around him, sirens blared and warning
lights flashed a stark, threatening red.
He cursed and muttered under his breath.
Just an hour ago, things had been under control,
neat and orderly, standard running operations,
and now they were staring down the barrel
of both a Broken Masquerade Scenario and a
potential XK Class End of the World Scenario.
And on a more personal level, four of the
meanest, nastiest, and deadliest anomalies
were on his tail.
They’d breached containment, compromised
site security, and now they were out for revenge.
What was happening?
How had this group of anomalies gotten out,
and why were they all after Dr. Bright?
And most importantly of all, how could everything
have gone to hell in a handbasket so fast?
Let’s rewind the clock and see.
The morning had begun in the break room.
Dr. Bright was enjoying a nice cup of hot
coffee and a danish, watching the news.
It was, by all accounts, an incredibly boring
day.
The reports were economic figures, a few dry
statistics about unemployment, and then live
coverage of a presidential press conference
on the White House lawn.
Dr. Bright was halfway through a thought about
how he’d hated his brief period of time
inhabiting the body of George W. Bush and
running the country when the president started
melting over his podium on live TV.
As well as his guards.
And the press corps.
And the camera people.
It was a sight so shocking it made Dr. Bright
drop his coffee cup, and almost drop his danish!
He slipped out his phone and fired off a text
to O5-1, the leader of the O5 Council, simply
saying, “We may have a problem.”
To which he received the quick and emphatic
reply, “YOU THINK!?”
Dr. Bright started frantically changing the
channel.
He wanted to know if some anomalous troublemaker
had just melted the President and those around
him, perhaps to destabilize the US government
- that’d be a textbook Chaos Insurgency
move - or if they were looking at something
considerably more dangerous.
And considering every single channel Dr. Bright
changed to started displaying a “Signal
Interrupted” message, now was probably not
the time to be optimistic.
It was here.
The big one.
The one they’d all been waiting for.
Battle stations: Engaged.
Across Site-19, the protocols were enacted
to put everything on total lockdown: Nobody
in, nobody out.
It was lucky for everyone inside that hadn’t
already been exposed that this protocol also
involved the automatic shuttering of every
single window in the building.
Dr. Bright and a crack team of senior researchers
and administrators gathered in the site’s
command center and opened up a live video
link to O5-1.
They might make some sense of all this chaos
now, and figure out a good battle plan.
“So, what’s the situation, boss?”
Dr. Bright asked.
O5-1 let out a deep, rattling sigh.
“Well, Jack, things are about as bad as
they ever have been, so I’ll try my best
to take inventory.
A quarter of the council is gone - They got
exposed and stopped reporting in during the
initial shift.
That includes O5-9 on the orbiting base, given
she probably got the most direct exposure.”
A senior administrator raised their hand and
asked, “Exposure to what, sir?”
O5-1 took a grave pause before saying…
“Sunlight.
That seems to be what we’re up against here.
The one common denominator that seems to connect
everyone experiencing these anomalous effects
is direct sunlight exposure.
It causes people to take on a kind of... gelatinous
state.
And it isn’t just people, either.
It’s all living anomalies, too.
Something about this new sun thing, it’s
almost like it cancels out all previous anomalous
effects.
The only anomalies that seem to be exempt
are the ones who aren’t even made out of
flesh.”
Dr. Bright, who had a tendency to make jokes
as an emotional defense mechanism when things
got tough, chimed in with, “On a semi-related
note, anyone here feel like taking the lizard
for a walk?”
The few nervous chuckles in the room were
cut off by O5-1 slamming his fist against
the table over the video link.
Everyone fell into deathly silence.
“Damn it, Jack, this is no laughing matter!
The Foundation, and the rest of the human
race, is decimated right now.
We’re looking at billions dead already,
or at least, changed.
And even our people, a good portion of them
are reading the tea leaves and abandoning
their posts to spend what could be their last
hours with their families.
It’s imperative we take control of this
situation right now.
It may be our last chance.
So get your asses in gear and make it happen!”
And with that, the video link was cut off,
and the ragtag leaders of Site-19 got to work.
Taking what they knew about this lethal new
scenario, Dr. Bright had his subordinates
record and release one of the most significant
videos of the 21st century, or perhaps even
all of time, to be broadcasted on every communication
channel the Foundation could possibly hijack:
TV, radio, social media, YouTube, Twitch,
all global news outlets.
The SCP Foundation was going public.
People all over the world - huddled in the
dark, terrified of the horrors they’d seen
through windows or out of the safety of shady
corners - noticed that all the screens around
them started playing the same thing in perfect
synchronicity.
It was flashing red, with an unfamiliar logo,
while a commanding voice droned on with the
only instructions that might give them hope
for survival.
“This is a Public Service Announcement from
the SCP Foundation.
We are commandeering all broadcast channels
and frequencies to deliver a vital message.
Avoid sunlight at all costs.
Cover your bodies thoroughly.
And follow the instructions on the screen
to reach the nearest operational SCP Foundation
containment site…”
Back at Site-19, Dr. Bright and everyone they
had left were preparing for a sudden influx
of refugees from the outside.
Any members of D-Class personnel who weren’t
psychopathic killers were deputized as honorary
Foundation personnel and brought in to help
convert empty wings into sleeping and living
areas.
Bright, who was still trying to hold on to
some semblance of humor in this dark time,
thought to himself, “Well if I knew we were
going to be entertaining guests, I would have
cleaned the place up a little more.
Maybe bought some new throw pillows and a
scented candle or two.”
And make no mistake, it was indeed an incredibly
dark time.
It had only been a few hours since the phenomenon
started, and already, it was Hell out there.
Society had already effectively collapsed
during the chaos.
The streets were filled with the shambling
remains of melted nightmare people.
The sun shone far above like some all-powerful
tyrant, gazing its single, deadly eye down
on all of humanity.
For billions upon billions of years, it had
given this solar system life.
Now, all it had for them was death and destruction.
For those trapped outside, there was only
one hope of survival: Getting to one of these
“SCP Foundation” containment sites.
At least those people somehow knew what was
going on here...
Little did these unfortunate refugees of a
horribly and irreparably changed world know,
that all was not well in the world of the
SCP Foundation.
As the hours marched on, Broken Masquerade
scenario and possible XK aside, it seemed
to Dr. Bright that they actually had a handle
on the situation, all things considered.
And what’s more, the night was about to
fall, allowing for free movement outside.
This would be a boon for people hoping to
reach Site-19 with minimal risk of exposure.
But refugees wouldn’t be the only thing
coming to Site-19 that day.
Hours earlier and miles away, something terrible
happened at Containment Area 25b - an extensive
and heavily guarded containment site with
only one inmate.
During the initial panic of the event that
they were now codenaming When Day Breaks,
many of the guards were exposed, and several
others abandoned their posts in panic, knowing
that the world as they had all grown to know
it had come to an end.
This left the place grievously under-guarded.
200 meters under the sea, in the true heart
of the containment area, an obsidian coffin
was surrounded by a confused and terrified
skeleton crew.
And the term “Skeleton Crew” was about
to take on a far more literal meaning, as
the obsidian coffin they were trying in vain
to keep contained started to rattle.
Fast forward by twenty minutes and every single
member of Foundation personnel at Containment
Area 25b was dead, and SCP-076-2, the legendary
immortal warrior, Able, was standing in the
ruins of the base.
While it would be easy to write Able off as
a mindless killing machine because of the
sheer ferocity he brings to a battle, the
reality couldn’t be further from the case.
He had the kind of tactical intelligence that
human supercomputers wouldn’t develop for
another several centuries - if the world hadn’t
ended already.
From the visual evidence he’d gleaned upon
escaping, he already knew that sunlight had
turned deadly, turning everyone who was exposed
into these feeble blobs.
So, if he hoped to continue his killing frenzy
elsewhere, he’d need to create his own shade
during transit.
That would be simple enough.
With a cruel smirk, Able picked up one of
the reinforced blast doors he’d so easily
burst through earlier.
The sheer weight of it would have crushed
a mortal man, but for Able, this was little
more than a light workout.
He lifted the door above his head like a parasol,
bathing himself in the cool shade, before
taking off at impossible speeds.
He’d remembered a lot from his days under
the Foundation’s employ as part of the disastrous
Pandora’s Box Mobile Task Force, and one
of those things was the location of Site-19.
There’d be plenty of warriors for him to
send to their makers there...
Back at Site-19, where Able would very shortly
arrive, Dr. Bright and his team were helping
the first wave of outsiders into the confines
of the building.
At first, it had seemed like a good idea,
something they could sustain, but now, Dr.
Bright was starting to worry about all the
practical considerations.
How would they keep potentially thousands,
or even tens of thousands of people, fed,
clothed, and watered for an extended period
of time?
Sure, they had the infinite pizza box, but
pizza for three meals a day for weeks on end
was a fast track to everyone here dying of
scurvy.
These new worries were interrupted by a siren
that signaled familiar ones: There had been
a containment breach in several cells in the
humanoid containment wings.
Some of the low-risk or even friendly humanoids,
like SCP-343, aka God, had been let out to
assist in gathering survivors from the nighttime
chaos outside.
That meant anyone still locked up really,
really, really needed to stay locked up.
In other words, it was very bad news.
Dr. Bright cursed under his breath and instructed
his subordinates to keep focusing on the refugee
situation.
He shouldered an assault rifle and took off
into the bowels of the site, hoping he could
at least head off the escapees until some
guards or Mobile Task Forces from smaller
sites could reach Site-19 and help him in
getting them fully recontained.
This is just typical, he thought to himself.
When it rains, it pours.
We can never catch a break around here, can
we?
I should have followed my dreams and become
a competitive ice dancer, then I never would
have—
Dr. Bright’s self-pity was interrupted by
a brutal punch to the side of his head, which
laid him out against the wall.
He turned, vision swimming, and raised his
assault rifle, hoping to find a target in
the blur.
That’s when an obsidian blade swung at impossible
speed and cleaved his gun in half.
He could feel his breath hitch in his throat
as his vision recentered itself and he saw
the imposing, tattooed figure of Able standing
above him, wielding one of his trademark swords.
His dark eyes were burning with deadly intent.
“Hello, Jack,” he said.
“Long time no see.
I imagine I don’t need to remind you who
I am.”
Able laughed and Dr. Bright felt his muscles
tense in rage.
Of course, he knew Able.
Not only had the homicidal maniac been a consistent
thorn in the Foundation’s side since day
one, but he’d also been the one to change
Dr. Bright’s life forever.
It had been Able who had killed him as a junior
researcher when he was first carrying the
SCP-963 medallion.
It was Able who had cursed him with this terrible
immortality.
Dr. Bright despised him to his core.
“I’d like you to meet a few friends I
made since I got here, Jack,” Able said,
gesturing into the darkness of the hallway.
“Who said I was bad at teamwork?”
It was like something out of a nightmare.
First, SCP-106 stepped forward, dripping with
that terrible, black tar.
His face twisted into a manic grin that foretold
inhuman tortures to come.
Then came SCP-953, the devilish Polymorphic
Humanoid, claws and fangs bared, tails swaying.
And then, bafflingly, SCP-2430, the Immortal
Hitler Clone.
Dr. Bright tried to move but found the tip
of Able’s sword right in front of his face.
“It’s funny, Jack,” Able said.
“You’re an anomaly who kills to live.
How many people have worn your little necklace?
And yet you can swan around as you please,
while we rot away in containment.
We think it’s time for a little payback.”
Bright nodded.
“That makes sense, I guess.
But why’s he here?”
He pointed to the Immortal Hitler Clone, who
sneered, as usual.
“He thinks you’re Jewish,” said the
Polymorphic Humanoid, in Korean.
Dr. Bright rose uneasily to his feet, honestly
surprised that Able was allowing him to do
so.
He was lucky, in a sense.
It perhaps took a being as strong as Able
to hold these others at bay.
As much as Dr. Bright despised the man, he
offered a much quicker and more painless death
than the Old Man or the Polymorphic Humanoid.
It wouldn’t be anything he hadn’t experienced
before, after all.
Life could be a sick joke sometimes.
”So, what’s the plan?
You’re gonna kill me again?”
Dr. Bright asked.
The four nightmarish anomalies all began to
laugh.
“Well, in the end, yes,” Able said.
“But the world’s gone to hell.
Your people aren’t in control here anymore,
so we can take our time.
We will slaughter you and everyone else in
here.
If I were you, I’d run, Jack.”
He didn’t need to be told twice.
Jack ran for his life, too scared to even
look behind him as the sound of footsteps
got louder.
The only way things could possibly get worse
is if he somehow, amidst all this, suddenly
developed a hernia.
And the way this day was going, he really
wouldn’t have been surprised.
Dr. Bright turned a corner, and somehow, the
Polymorphic Humanoid was already there, standing
in front of him.
She gave a girlish giggle and swiped at him,
leaving four ragged claw marks on his chest.
Dr. Bright winced in pain and started running
in the other direction.
He reached an adjoining hallway and booked
it for the armory, hoping there he’d get
some serious firepower.
But SCP-106 suddenly phased through the wall
next to him, grabbing Dr. Bright by his lab
coat and throwing him against the opposite
wall with a flick of his wrist.
Bright scrambled to discard the coat, already
being eaten away by the Old Man’s caustic
fluids.
The Old Man just watched him and chuckled,
faintly amused at the whole affair.
These damn anomalies were in control now.
Dr. Bright got up and kept running.
The one saving grace was the fact that all
of these anomalies were too sadistic to outright
kill him just yet, so he still had the faintest
of chances.
He ran into the break room, tipping over shelves,
bookcases, and furniture to obstruct the path
behind him even slightly.
That’s when he heard the door behind him
open, followed by a wave of furious German
expletives as the Immortal Hitler Clone entered
the room to give chase.
However, moments later, Hitler fell to the
ground, clutching his foot and wailing in
agony.
You see, due to the circumstances of his creation
- Josef Stalin, Sarkic wizards, it was a whole
thing, we can’t get into it now - he felt
pain at three times the intensity of a normal
human being.
“Lieber Gott, I stubbed mein toe!” he
yelled.
Dr. Bright kept running.
From the break room, he entered a hallway
that would lead him back to the main barracks.
Perhaps there, he could get some reinforcements.
Then maybe he could—
His thoughts were once again cut off by Able
suddenly appearing and grabbing him by the
throat.
His grip was impossibly strong; Dr. Bright
was already seeing stars.
“Think you could get away that easily?”
Able hissed.
With horrifying strength, Able slammed Dr.
Bright up against one of the shuttered windows.
He struck it with such force he broke through
the shutter and the glass behind it, sailing
down to the ground outside.
They were lucky it was nighttime, or this
all would have been over already.
Able soon followed him down, cracking his
knuckles and assuming a fighting stance.
“Up on your feet, Jack,” Able said.
“I won’t kill a man lying down.
No honor in that.”
Jack rose, feeling pain in every inch of his
body.
Up against a seven-foot-tall, jacked monster
of a man with thousands of years of fighting
under his belt?
He stood mathematically zero chance.
But perhaps he could at least get some licks
in.
He ran at Able, screaming with years of pent-up
rage, and tried to attack him with a flurry
of blows.
But not a single one of them landed.
Able dodged every punch and returned them
with a force comparable to being hit by a
runaway train.
He knocked Dr. Bright to the ground and started
beating him relentlessly.
“All these lives I’ve given you, all this
extra time, and still, you haven’t learned
how to fight.
Pathetic!”
Able roared, punctuating his words with blows.
“Perhaps in a thousand years, you might
last sixty seconds against me.
You are a waste of your gift!”
Dr. Bright could already feel the life leaving
his body when something new entered the equation.
He could barely make it out through his bloody,
swollen eyes, but something huge was coming
toward them.
It was like flesh from so many of the melted
people had coagulated into some huge, mountainous
blob.
It was a sight so remarkable and horrifying
that even Able was distracted.
And Dr. Bright took advantage of the one chance
that gave him.
He took off his medallion and threw it at
the mass.
The life left his old body as SCP-963 deleted
the collection of tortured minds that made
up the terrible flesh monster, and replaced
them with only one: Dr. Jack Bright.
He felt new immense, monstrous strength well
up through him.
He was in the body of a true abomination,
and all of its power was his now.
“How about a round two, Able?” he thought.
The ancient warrior produced a pair of ebony
swords as Dr. Bright sent a swarm of fleshy
tendrils at him.
Able was quick, slicing off many of them,
but there was only so much he could take.
Soon, Dr. Bright’s new body was grabbing
Able’s every appendage, holding him in place
as he struggled with all his anomalous might.
But now, Dr. Bright’s rage had meaning,
with this new power to back it up.
He’d get a little revenge, at long last.
Time to go back in the box, Able...
It took longer than it would for any mortal
man, but eventually, it happened all the same.
Bright pushed and pulled in every direction,
applying every kind of pressure, leveraging
every ounce of his terrible new mass onto
Able’s body, until...
Crunch.
Dr. Bright relaxed his new body in final,
cathartic relief, dropping Able’s corpse
to the ground.
There was no denying, after everything that’d
happened, that it felt really, really, really
good.
The world may have ended, but at least Dr.
Bright got one win today.
Shirley woke up screaming, louder than usual
this time.
Bea, Shirley’s wife, sat bolt upright, as
though someone had just run a 20,000-volt
charge through her.
Her dirty hand clasped over Shirley’s mouth
until the awful sound stopped.
She whispered, “Baby, it was a dream, just
a dream!”
Shirley fell into a terrified silence, trying
to regulate her breathing.
They’d been hiding in an abandoned apartment
block for three days now, waiting for the
roads to clear, so they could take the chance
and move forward.
Bea, keeping close to the ground, scuttled
over to one of the smashed-out windows.
She stared down onto the street, thirty feet
below.
Midnight, no stars, cars crashed up against
each other from the initial panic.
And thank god, none of those things down there...
She breathed a sigh of relief and returned
to Shirley, gathering her up in her arms and
giving her a reassuring squeeze.
Her body was still trembling.
“What happened in this one?”
Bea asked.
Shirley exhaled and closed her eyes.
“We’re close now,” she said.
“We’re so close, Bea.”
It was the dreams that began this journey.
The quest for the last safe place.
Initially, Bea had thought it was a fool’s
errand - There were no “Safe” places in
this world anymore, nowhere that the sun or
its terrible monsters hadn’t touched.
But Shirley insisted otherwise.
She’d seen it in her dreams.
A place of almost mythical wonder, a vast
and complex facility, away from the light.
Site-19.
Shirley and Bea grabbed their backpacks and
shrugged them on.
It was best to set off now, get a few hours
of walking under their belts and find some
shelter before the sun came back up.
In the meantime, all they needed to do was
avoid the monsters lurking out there.
It was an interesting trade-off.
Once upon a time, years and years ago, when
the sun changed, there had been billions of
those things.
They were people once, until the new light
touched them and turned them into these slimy
abominations.
There was a time you couldn’t look out your
window without seeing hundreds of them slithering
past you.
Then, they started coagulating.
Becoming these huge, mountainous masses of
gloopy, melted flesh.
It was nice that they were fewer now, made
them easier to avoid, easier to sneak around.
But if one of those things found you, you
were dead.
Or more likely, you were about to be something
so much worse than dead.
The two women trekked down the side of the
road, keeping to the shadows, even in the
dark.
They were on the edge of the city now, and
it wouldn’t be long until they were in the
wilderness.
Pro: Being away from a population center meant
lower odds of being attacked by one of those
monsters.
Con: Fewer places to hide when the sun came
up.
In the meantime, all they could do was keep
walking and hope.
It was an almost supernatural mixture of luck
and skill that had gotten them this far.
They’d known each other for four years when
day broke and everything went to hell, but
they’d only been married for about a month
- it’d been a hell of a post-honeymoon wakeup
call.
So many had been changed in the initial panic,
and so many more had been destroyed by what
came after.
But these two weren’t just anybody.
In fact, it was the specific combination of
skills and knowledge these two possessed that’d
kept them alive for this long.
In the world that came before, Bea had been
a soldier who’d done two tours abroad and
seen active combat multiple times.
And Shirley had been a doctor, rising through
the ranks of a local hospital.
Between them, they could fight for and heal
one another, despite everything.
And in those early years, that’s all it
had been.
They were always moving, always avoiding the
terrors outside and the tyranny of the sun.
They’d avoided the dangers that’d destroyed
so many others, but they’d never dared to
hope.
Hope was lofty, impractical, it got people
killed.
They’d only ever tried to survive.
The immediate avoidance of death was a practical
goal.
Anything else was just confetti.
Until, of course, Shirley had started having
the dreams.
Some were just fragments, like sifting through
a stack of photographs in the middle of a
deep fog.
Others were full narratives, like movies in
her head, viewed in the first person.
But all of them were about the same thing:
She and Bea needed to make it to a place they
called “Site-19.”
Something about it was familiar, like a thing
she’d heard years ago.
Perhaps from those strange broadcasts that
were on every TV screen during the initial
chaos.
Oh, and of course, there was one more element
in the dream.
The one thing that made it seem more like
a nightmare.
In this part of the dream, she was already
in Site-19, and walking down a long, dark
hallway, somewhere far away from the sun.
There are a series of heavy reinforced doors
along the wall next to her.
Each one had a number on them, advancing as
she got further down the hall: 029, 030, 031,
032...
That’s when she’d hear the voice.
That awful, terrible voice.
“Shirley...
Oh, Shirley...
Come closer...
Don’t you want to see my face?
I’m Smiling, Shirley.
I’d like you to see it...”
She’d reach the door marked 035, at which
point, the next door slowly creaked open.
Even after all the terrifying things they’d
seen in the new world, this somehow paralyzed
her with fear every time.
It was a kind of dread she’d never experienced
before.
Something that looked like black water would
start seeping out from the opening door, then
footsteps, getting closer.
A shambling figure would emerge from the open
door.
It was hard to make it out fully in the dark,
but somehow, she just intuitively knew what
was coming toward her.
It had a stark-white face, like a mask, with
nothing but darkness where the eyes should
be.
Down below, the body, seemingly heavily injured
and dripping with that same black water, was
one she recognized.
Her own.
She couldn’t move.
The masked figure, this masked version of
her, kept getting closer, dripping with more
and more of that black water.
It was shaking, almost vibrating.
Then she realized, it was laughing.
”See you soon, Shirley,” it said.
“Can’t wait for you and Bea to visit...”
And that was when she woke up screaming.
Somehow, despite the grim ending, some part
of Shirley knew that she and Bea needed to
get to Site-19.
Only there would she be safe, and perhaps
even find the answers to how all this horror
had even transpired.
They were already risking their lives out
here every day, wouldn’t it be worth it
to find the truth?
The duo continued to trudge through the night.
It was, they thanked their lucky stars, a
relatively uneventful journey.
They encountered one of the flesh beasts on
the edge of town, but they were able to hide
inside a nearby bus depot until it slithered
on, gibbering incoherent madness.
After waiting to make sure it was gone, the
duo left the city and ventured out into the
badlands, Shirley continuing to insist that
the legendary Site-19 from her dreams was
definitely close by now.
Bea looked up at the sky and chimed in, “I
hope you’re right, honey, or you and me
are fried eggs.”
Shirley and Bea walked for another several
hours, each becoming more silently anxious
that the sun would rise before they reached
ample cover, and everything they worked for
would be taken away from them.
This terror persisted until, against all odds,
a huge, black shape started to emerge along
the horizon.
The sight of it made Shirley’s eyes widen
in amazement.
“That’s it, Bea,” she said.
“Site-19.
Just like it was in my dreams...”
They passed the chain-link fence around the
perimeter, approaching this large, seemingly
abandoned building like it was the Lost City
Of El Dorado.
Bea was astonished.
She loved Shirley, of course, and had faith
in her beliefs, but something about a place
prophesied in a dream actually being real
was honestly nothing short of a miracle.
The two of them approached the fortified front
door and heaved it open together.
Against all odds, they could see light inside
the building.
They still had power here!?
Nowhere had power anymore!
Maybe this place really was salvation, after
all...
As the two closed the door behind them, they
noticed that the windows all around them were
shuttered.
It must have been some precautionary measure
against the new sun.
Smart.
Whoever these people were, they’d thought
ahead.
They’d had some kind of preparation for
all this.
So, Bea couldn’t help but wonder, where
had they all gone now?
As the two ventured deeper into the building,
Bea unholstered a handgun that she’d been
keeping in her jacket.
It was no good against the flesh monsters,
but it was a worthwhile deterrent against
other desperate people out on the road.
Lucky for them, she hadn’t needed to fire
it.
Yet.
Other than the power being on somehow, the
place seemed abandoned.
They traveled from room to room - offices,
filing areas, what seemed like laboratories,
libraries, rest areas.
There was no real indication of what these
people, whoever they were, actually did around
here.
After searching through a few different files,
all written in almost incomprehensible short-hand
and code, Shirley at least found a name to
put to these people: The SCP Foundation.
Was it some kind of charity?
They ventured deeper until they found a hall
marked “D-Class Bunks.”
Inside, they found bunk beds stacked on top
of each other.
Enough to hold hundreds of people.
Bea wondered aloud whether this was some kind
of secret paramilitary outfit.
It was the one thing that might explain everything
they’d seen here today.
And in all fairness, she was at least partially
right.
“Okay, ladies, hold it right there!”
Shirley and Bea turned around to see a man
in an orange jumpsuit standing a few feet
behind them.
He was carrying an assault rifle, and training
it on both of them.
He was a tall, imposing man, and yet, he was
shaking.
Bea lowered her gun.
Neither she nor Shirley said a word.
“You’re human, right?” he said, voice
trembling slightly.
“What?”
Shirley replied.
“Just answer the damn question!”
There was a tense pause, where nobody there
seemed to know what might happen to them next.
The stranger’s finger started curling around
the trigger.
It was Bea who broke the silence.
“We look human, don’t we?”
she said.
Another moment passed.
The gun rattled in the stranger’s hands.
He exhaled and lowered the barrel, taking
a more relaxed stance.
“Sorry,” he said.
“Can’t be too careful, the kind of stuff
they used to keep in here.
It’d give you nightmares.
I’m Mike, by the way.”
He approached, tentatively shaking Shirley
and Bea’s hands, just to prove to them that
he wasn’t the kind of guy who liked to gun
down random women.
He asked them whether they were hungry, and
when they told him they hadn’t eaten anything
but protein bars in over a week, he told them
he was about to show them something incredible:
The Site-19 Break Room.
Not long after that, Shirley, Bea, and Mike
were all sitting around, enjoying some defrosted
hot pockets.
At that moment, no three-course meal cooked
up by a five-star chef could ever even compare.
As they ate together, Mike told his story.
“The people who used to run this place,
believe me, they were nutjobs.
Sure, back in the day, I wasn’t such a nice
guy.
Me and some other knuckleheads, we needed
the money, so we robbed a few places.
People got caught in the crossfire, next thing
I know, I’m on death row.
Then these men in white coats, they came and
told me I could get a commuted sentence if
I came and took part in some experiments for
them.
That’s how they got me into their house
of horrors right here...”
If Shirley and Bea hadn’t lived through
the apocalyptic hell of When Day Breaks, they
might not have believed Mike.
He told them about how this “SCP Foundation”
used to use humans in experiments, subjecting
them to all the monsters they had locked up
down here.
There was this giant reptile that couldn’t
be killed.
Some freaky statue that’d snap your neck
if you stopped looking at it.
But the one that’d frightened him the most,
the one that’d haunted his dreams, ever
since he got here...
“The Mask,” Shirley said aloud, lost in
thought.
Mike was taken aback.
How had she known what was he going to say?
It did nothing to reduce his fear when she
told him that she’d been dreaming about
the Mask for over a month now.
Stark white, with black water dripping from
it.
Everyone was silent for a moment.
Bea and Mike just stared at Shirley, equal
parts amazed and frightened.
Mike cleared his throat and told Shirley that
in the years that had passed since day broke,
the population of Site-19 had slowly dwindled.
Monsters had escaped, the flesh beasts had
slithered in and taken others.
Over time, most of the staff had either died,
changed, or left.
All that was left here was him.
Him, and the Mask.
Luckily for him, he’d never been directly
“cross-tested” with it.
Because those who got tested with the Mask
never came back.
Sometimes, he could hear it whispering in
his dreams, trying to leak itself into his
mind, drip by drip, poisoning his soul.
The one saving grace was that, being a mask,
it couldn’t exactly walk up and tap you
on the shoulder.
All you needed to do was stay away from it,
and you’d be fine.
The Mask couldn’t hurt you on its own.
The three of them carried on talking for the
last hours of the morning.
Night had become day and day had become night,
it was the easiest way to survive these days.
Or at least, survive as yourself.
Bea and Shirley told Mike how they’d met
in college, all those years ago.
Mike told them the story of how he managed
to survive by hiding in a broom closet while
some gangly, white monstrosity chased down
and slaughtered the rest of his bunkmates.
The tiredness took them all again, and they
decided to bed down in the D-Class Bunks.
They were more comfortable than the bedrolls
that Shirley and Bea had been sleeping on
in abandoned buildings for the last year or
so.
To Mike, this place had been a living Hell
once upon a time.
But now, for a brief period in this terrifying
new world, it could be Heaven.
Shirley drifted off to uneasy sleep, trying
her best to ignore the whispers.
In what only felt like a few moments, her
eyes fluttered back open.
She was in a new place, but one that felt
oddly familiar.
A long, dark hallway, bordered on one side
by a series of iron doors.
She turned her head slightly, eyes still adjusting
to the darkness.
The number on the door next to her read, “027.”
Further down the hall, Shirley saw a dark
figure, standing tall, shoulders broad and
back erect as a ballet dancer.
As her vision came back into focus, she saw
the shock of orange.
It was Mike, wearing that same orange jumpsuit.
He was standing about ten or fifteen feet
away, staring in the opposite direction.
“Mike?”
Shirley said, operating on the foggy half-logic
of a dream.
He didn’t respond.
With growing concern, she started stepping
closer.
“Mike?”
That’s when she noticed something else:
Black water, pooled around Mike’s feet.
The sight of it stopped her in her tracks
and froze the breath in her throat.
With an almost audible creak, Mike turned
around.
A grinning, white mask covered up his face.
“Hello, Shirley,” it said.
“So lovely to finally meet, face to face,
eh?
I bet you’re so glad you ran into me.
After all, sleepwalking can be dangerous...”
Shirley screamed and ran in the other direction,
wasting no time at all.
She heard the slow, measured footsteps of
Mike, wearing the Mask, behind her.
It was in no rush; it walked like a masked
killer in a horror movie.
“Why run?”
the voice said, “I’ve got all day, and
I know you can’t leave while the sun’s
up, darling.
You and your beloved are all mine, it’s
only a matter of time...”
Somehow, despite her being so far ahead, the
voice sounded like it was right next to her
ear.
Like it wasn’t speaking out of its mouth,
it was just talking directly into her brain.
With every syllable, her mind started to slow,
like the Mask’s voice was tar seeping in
between the gears.
Soon enough, her legs stopped working.
Shirley was frozen in place, hearing the footsteps
of the Masked Mike behind her.
Her brain was flooding with dark thoughts:
Death, pain, torture, grief, the final smothering
of all hope and happiness.
There was really nothing like it, like every
nightmare she’d ever experienced being collected
into one terrible elixir and poured onto her
mind.
So this was what that horrible mask could
do...
Soon enough, the Masked Mike had passed her
and turned to look directly at her face.
There was an awful smell, like chemicals and
burning flesh.
She turned her gaze downwards, seeing that
it looked like Mike’s body was somehow melting
away from all that black water.
It was like acid.
“Mike was a weak host,” the Mask said,
as if it was replying to her thoughts.
“He won’t last much longer, but that’s
fine, I’m looking forward to taking you
for a whirl, Dear Shirley.
And when your hands are mine, you can only
imagine the terrible things I’m going to
do to your beloved Bea with them.”
Shirley, with all her willpower, was able
to move her mouth enough to force out the
words, “Don’t you dare touch her...”
The monster laughed, just like it always did
in her dream.
“That’s not your choice to make, anymore,”
it said.
The Mask reached for her with Mike’s melting
fingers, fizzling away with all that black
slime, getting so close to caressing her tender
cheek.
All that awful silence was only broken by
the sound of a soft clicking behind it, then
a gunshot passing through the back of its
stolen head.
The Mask turned, more shocked than anything,
to see Bea standing there, wielding Mike’s
old assault rifle and aiming it with deadly
accuracy.
Before the Mask could breathe another poisonous
word, Bea opened fire, releasing a volley
of bullets into the last of its melting body
as it staggered back into the darkened hallway.
Shirley watched in astonishment as the creature
fell, Mike’s body splattering into a puddle,
and sending the Mask itself skidding down
the hallway.
Maybe it was just a trick of the mind, but
she could swear the Mask was frowning now,
not smiling.
Bea breathed a sigh of relief and said, “I’m
thinking it’s probably better if this place
stays abandoned.”
Shirley, who hadn’t quite regained her speech
yet, just smiled, nodded, and embraced Bea.
They shared a kiss, just happy to still be
together and alive, despite it all.
Come nightfall, they left again, in search
of another place.
The Possessive Mask remained there, laying
on the floor of some anonymous Site-19 Hallway.
Just waiting for some unlucky, weak-minded
survivor to wander in, and try it on...
While some higher-level researchers, specialized
guards, and containment experts at the SCP
Foundation have fixed anomalous projects tailored
to their very particular set of skills, for
many lower-level operatives - including junior
researchers, guards, janitorial staff, and
even the dreaded D-Classes - every day is
showing up, spinning the wheel of misfortune,
and finding out how you might die today.
Will you be hacked to pieces by a murder monster?
Pulled into a portal?
Turned into a doll?
Eaten alive?
Made into a living nest by bugs?
Stretched out and broken?
Drowned?
Exsanguinated?
Set on fire?
Beaten to death by a volley of anomalous tomatoes
because you decided to drop a cringeworthy
dad joke or a rancid pun?
There are perhaps only a handful of anomalies
that not only will not harm you, but will
actively enrich your life by getting to spend
time with them.
And of course, chief among these is the legendary
SCP-999, also known by its adorable moniker,
The Tickle Monster.
We don’t need to go into too much detail
in describing this gelatinous ray of sunshine,
his anomalous delightfulness has made him
somewhat of a celebrity compared to the murderer’s
row of terrifying entities and monsters around
him.
The researcher assigned to him today was troubled,
having seen one of his favorite coworkers
devoured by SCP-682 the day before.
Getting assigned to feeding and checking on
SCP-999 today was exactly what he needed.
As he entered the room, several bags of M&Ms
in hand, the creature cooed, perhaps sensing
his tension, and approached him.
Immediately, the researcher felt a wave of
calm and contentment wash over him.
The incredible and rare feeling that perhaps,
everything is going to be alright for once.
999 rubbed up against his leg as he poured
M&Ms into its eager mouth, radiating good
vibes the whole time.
What an asset.
What a gift.
And to think, this adorable little goober
was prophesied to someday save the world.
That much seemed almost funny.
But he was certainly more than capable of
saving the life of someone who hadn’t felt
the warmth of internal sunshine in quite some
time, and for that much, the researcher was
profoundly grateful.
He left 999’s chamber that day with a renewed
sense of hope for the future.
That maybe, just maybe, they might be able
to pull through, to make a difference, to
push this crazy ball of rock we call our home
in the right direction.
Maybe someday, the sun would rise on a perfect
world.
Who would have thought that a strange sunrise
could change everything?
Emergency sirens went off across the globe,
but in every case, they were drowned out by
a terrible and endless chorus of screams.
But below all that, you’d hear another gut-wrenching
sound: A low but pervasive sizzling, like
an egg on a hot pan, as billions of human
beings started to change their states of matter.
The SCP Foundation had fought off and contained
so many seemingly impossible threats.
From interdimensional horrors like the Hanged,
Sealed, and Scarlet Kings, to nightmarish
mass killers like SCP-106, the Old Man, SCP-096,
the Shy Guy, and SCP-682, The Hard to Destroy
Reptile.
In their many battles against the anomalous,
they’d developed incredible methodologies
and exceedingly advanced technology.
But what good would any of it do when the
very center of our solar system decided in
an instant that rather than being the lynchpin
of our delicate cradle of life, it would instead
be the horrible instrument of all of our demises?
This awful hypothetical was answered upon
the emergence of SCP-001 - A terrible day
also known as When Day Breaks.
In the snap of one’s fingers, half the world
was plunged into terror and death.
Rays of stark, red light swept through the
streets.
People lucky enough to be in the shade, or
inside buildings with a view to the outside,
saw the people in the streets seize up and
begin to shriek in terrible pain.
Their skin sagged and their bones liquified.
Their bodies dropped down to the ground and
coalesced into gurgling, retching puddles
the color of melted flesh.
Those who saw this abomination happening would
never forget it.
It would stay with them for the rest of their
lives.
It would endure, like a stain on their retinas,
an afterimage burned into the plasma of an
old TV screen.
But here’s a slight consolation: For most
of the human race, “the rest of their lives”
wouldn’t be that long.
The sudden insanity taking over the world
caused the SCP Foundation to do something
drastic: Step out of the shadows.
Metaphorically speaking, of course.
The legendary Foundation motto had been reversed:
They would die in the light so that humanity
could live on in the dark.
Thankfully, the very concept of the day gave
them one advantage: While one side of the
earth was effectively doomed the second the
process began, the other side had a twelve-hour
head-start before the sun turned its terrible
eye to them.
Sirens went off in the middle of the night,
waking people up, groggy, rubbing the sleep
from their eyes.
Every television and radio and internet-enabled
device in their home was playing the same
message, direct from the SCP Foundation - Which
had now effectively commandeered the entire
US government, along with the rest of the
world.
It gave them directions to the nearest Foundation
containment site and told them that if they
didn’t immediately comply and find their
way to safety, they would experience a terrible
death by sunrise.
And if you’re at all familiar with human
beings, you’ve probably already predicted
that they didn’t just calmly wrap themselves
up, make their way to their cars, and form
an orderly line to the various Foundation
containment sites located around them.
It was, in fact, total pandemonium.
As the solar clock ticked down, slowly marking
off the seconds that anyone outside had left
to live, the only human beings with a meaningful
head start began to go insane in a number
of varied and interesting ways.
Some who took the situation seriously, and
acknowledged that the sun was indeed going
to wipe out most of humanity, simply cracked
under the pressure.
There were those who went into totally catatonic
states, rocking back and forth in the corner
and refusing to respond to any stimuli.
Some became erratic and violent, with unpredictable
behavior that harmed themselves and others.
After all, what was the point in acting normally
anymore when the complete crumbling of human
civilization was imminent, and their only
hope was some shadowy organization they’d
never heard of?
Some, not heeding the warnings seriously enough,
and prompted by greed and opportunism, tried
to take advantage of the situation financially.
Some smashed windows of local stores and looted,
or broke into the homes of neighbors who had
already fled in hopes of purloining their
property.
Others were a little more creative: Setting
up short-term, everything must go, nighttime
fire sales for their brands of essential oils,
nootropics, and nutriceuticals, claiming all
of them have the power to ward off or cure
the new effects of the sun.
Others completely denied the possibility that
any of this was real, and claimed that the
messages from this so-called “SCP Foundation”
were actually just a front to take away their
freedoms and trap them in underground government
camps.
They staunchly refused to follow any of the
safety guidelines that the SCP Foundation
put out, claiming, “If you try to take away
my first amendment rights, you’re gonna
taste my second amendment rights!”
While riding around in their pick-up trucks
and SUVs, blasting Kid Rock’s “Don’t
Tell Me How To Live” at earsplitting volumes.
Naturally, they had all melted into screeching
puddles of liquid flesh by sunrise.
Some were not victims of their own bizarre
choices but were doomed by the sudden terrible
fear and panic of the circumstances themselves.
The highways were gridlocked, cars stuck as
far as the eye could see.
So many had rushed to escape during the initial
wave that means of transport soon became choke
points, like clogged arteries in a dying man.
People do irrational things when they’re
scared: Riots broke out on the streets.
Fighting, killing, burning.
Everyone hoping for some means of meager control
over a situation that had long been out of
any of their hands.
Some were too far away with not enough time
to close the distance.
What could they really do but just sit around
and wait to die?
The hours marched on as the earth made its
slow turn towards the sun, leaving one decimated
half in darkness and the other a sitting duck
for its terrible effects.
Hundreds of thousands had made their way to
the containment sites and safely gotten inside,
but still, so many millions were left outside.
It was a slaughterhouse.
One great, big global meat grinder, and every
moment that passed, the handle turned, and
any humans left outside got just that little
bit closer to the grinding, gnashing gears
below.
Site-19, being the largest containment site
on the Foundation’s books, also became humanity’s
only bastion.
It was the greatest hope of escape from the
horrors going on outside.
The Foundation had figured out so many ways
of counteracting deadly anomalous forces before,
given enough time and enough personnel, surely
they could figure out a solution to even this?
This was, however, when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the survivors:
Those who were melted by the sudden hostile
sun weren’t dead.
They were very much alive, in fact, but they’d
been changed - In both body and mind.
What had once been humans now became terrible
beasts.
Half-melted gelatinous nightmares that coagulated
into even bigger beasts.
They got it into their head that they were
grateful for the transformation.
That they had been liberated from their old
forms in the old world.
They were something so much more now...
And they wanted everyone else to join them
in their liberation.
Survivors outside the Foundation containment
sites were systematically hunted by these
great masses of altered flesh.
Even those smart enough to cover every inch
of their bodies with clothes to protect from
the sun, to only move at night, to carry weapons,
were dragged out by meaty tendrils from their
refuges in basements and the lightless hearts
of buildings.
Dragged into the searing gaze of the sun.
To melt, to change, to coalesce into something
greater.
It was the inevitable fate of all of humanity.
When most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed, the flesh masses started turning
their attention to the Foundation containment
sites that were keeping all these poor, deluded
people from salvation.
They mounted offensives against the bases,
which the Foundation, with what remained of
their manpower and advanced weaponry, did
what they could to repel the attacks.
But every single day, it got harder.
Thankfully, for the people holed up at Site-19,
there was one consolation out there to help:
SCP-999.
The Foundation was at war with the sun and
its terrible disciples, and contrary to many
people’s beliefs, it takes more than men,
equipment, and bullets to win a war.
999 provided the essential element that brought
it all together: Morale, hope, the will to
go on, even when it seemed like all could
be lost.
After a long day of battling the fleshy abominations
at the gates, Foundation guards, Mobile Task
Force members, and even civilian volunteers
were drained and traumatized by the horrors
that they’d seen.
Once a day was over, 999 would move among
their ranks, cuddling up to them, warding
off the despair that was easy to set in during
the downswing of a terrible apocalypse like
this.
Without his presence, there would be no hope
of fighting that good fight.
So many of them would have given up, walked
into the sun, and joined the monstrous force
they were fighting.
After all, they seemed happy enough, and it
would certainly be easier.
999 had become, once again, an indispensable
asset to the SCP Foundation.
The solar betrayal may not have been the Scarlet
King’s doing - Well, as far as our current
intel suggests, anyway - but he was playing
a crucial part in saving the world, exactly
as predicted.
999 didn’t fully understand what was going
on outside sometimes, why there seemed to
be fewer people as the weeks went on, and
why the people there seemed so sad all the
time whenever he wasn’t helping them, but
he was more than happy to help, whatever the
case.
Many of the humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no harm
to people inside the site were released from
their containment chambers.
They needed everyone and everything they could
get in what seemed like a hopelessly one-sided
fight against the very concept of being outside.
Many of the larger, vacated chambers were
now filled with refugees from the outside,
many of whom had lost everything and everyone
they’d ever known to the horrors out there.
999 made the rounds in these areas regularly,
and through the D-Class cots, which had been
repurposed into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified refugees.
The adjustment to this new life - and to the
knowledge of all the secrets that had been
kept from them for all these years - wasn’t
exactly easy on their psyches, but spending
time with that soft, yellow blob that seemed
to smell exactly like their favorite scent
from the old world made everything better.
He was a savior in dark times, slithering
from person to person, giving hope where there
was none.
People opened up about their problems and
their fears - which, these days, were remarkably
similar - and though 999 couldn’t reply,
for many it was enough just to feel like they
were being listened to.
He was a soft, blobby shoulder to cry on,
and after day broke, everyone needed a good,
old-fashioned cry.
However, one day, while wandering the long,
dark corridors of Site-19, he saw a different
kind of crying.
It was a woman with an unfamiliar face - probably
one of the rare new refugees - bawling her
eyes out to a Foundation Senior Researcher
and an accompanying guard with an assault
rifle.
Hot, fat tears were rolling down her dirty
cheeks, her shaking hands clasped in prayer.
She was begging the researcher and the guard
to let her go outside.
She said that her son was still out there,
hiding away in the back room of a bank where
she used to work.
They got separated.
She needed to go back and find him.
Sadly, the researcher and the guard told her
that this was out of the question.
Official orders stated that anyone outside
the base at this time was to be considered
lost.
Letting her out there to find her son would
essentially be condemning her to death.
No human could go out there safely.
But of course, SCP-999 isn’t, by any definition,
a human.
When night fell, and everyone else was hunkered
down inside, 999 found a small crack in the
wall and slithered out of it.
It may not have been communicative in the
way most humans were, but 999 was indeed an
intelligent being, and knew intuitively that
if it left through a more obvious route, its
human caretakers here at the SCP Foundation
might try to stop it.
And when it came to saving this little boy,
999 refused to let anyone stop it.
999 slithered out and through the broken streets.
There were no bodies, of course.
It seemed even the dead could be revived and
assimilated through the power of the sun.
Talk about a mixed miracle.
But the broken-down world outside Site-19
undeniably reflected the pandemonium that
took place here.
999 would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the sun
rose.
He lost a few hours even finding his way to
the nearest town, where it was safe to assume
that the little boy was trapped.
He saw some of those...
Things... on the way there.
Those moving, wailing mountains of melted
human flesh, each talking and chattering to
themselves in a hundred different dead voices.
999 had been cross-tested with SCP-682, and
still, those monsters frightened him.
He decided it would be best to stay away from
them and make sure that they never saw him
out here.
Eventually, 999 reached the town: Similarly
dilapidated and broken down in the months
since the world as we had all known it disappeared
in a ray of terrible sunshine.
More great, gibbering blobs of flesh patrolled
the streets, looking for converts to integrate
into their biomass. 999 could only hope it
wasn’t already too late for the little boy.
999 discretely slithered from building to
building, until it could identify one as this
“bank” that the boy’s distraught mother
had been mentioning.
It thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was, from the years of stressed
Foundation employees telling it about the
money troubles they were suffering outside
of work.
It was another great example of it paying
to listen.
Eventually, it did slither into the correct
building, and it heard the extremely quiet
whimpering of the little boy inside.
It could feel the sadness and the fear radiating
off of him, as it was the creature’s natural
instinct to help the needy, and it used those
signals like homing beams to find the scared
little boy.
He’d hidden inside a broom closet and was
quietly weeping into his hands.
He hadn’t eaten in days, and was only surviving
by drinking the filthy water from the mop
bucket sitting next to him.
999 immediately embraced the boy, covering
him in its healing energy until the tears
on the boy’s face eventually dried.
999 cooed and chirped pleasantly until the
little boy was laughing again.
But this momentary joy was soon interrupted.
A great, heaving weight dragged itself down
the hall outside.
Both 999 and the boy could sense its monstrous
presence.
As it got closer, they could hear all of those
chattering voices, those poisonous whispers.
When it passed the door, they heard it speaking,
its voice practically vibrating with the hum
of malicious lunacy.
“Turn, pretty flowers, turn towards the
sun.
Feel it on your face.
Feel yourself change and sluice and mix into
us.
Become one with our army of one.
It must be so lonely to be you, little flower.
Walk into the sun and be us...”
999 and the boy remained silent in the broom
closet for hours as the great shape patrolled
the bank outside, searching for converts,
for victims.
At times, it seemed too frightening to even
breathe, fearing that would be enough to make
the monster detect them.
It felt like an eternity until the monster
eventually did slope off, and leave them in
the comforting quiet and darkness of the closet.
Now, they might be free.
999 could escort the boy safely back to the
containment site and into the arms of his
terrified mother.
But when they opened the door, they saw a
terrible sight: Light, in the distance, pouring
through the windows and the glass double doors.
It wouldn’t be safe to go out that way.
Upon seeing this, and putting together what
it meant, the boy began to cry.
He couldn’t take another night in the closet.
It was all going to whither from here...
Until 999 had a wonderful idea.
Hours later, when the Foundation’s guards
manned the turrets at the entrance of Site-19,
waiting for the inevitable onslaught of the
melted flesh creatures, they tensed up, seeing
a bobbing gelatinous form slithering towards
them in the distance.
The guards, who’d learned the hard way from
too many lost men that
it was better to
be safe than sorry, drew a bead on the distant
shape and prepared to fire - When suddenly,
their superior raised a hand and said:
“Wait! Hold fire!
Is that...999?”
And it was.
They all stared in astonishment as 999, chipper
as ever, came towards them through the sun.
It looked as though the opacity of its yellow
cytoplasm had increased, but other than that,
it was unaffected.
Turns out, the sun couldn’t melt what was
already melted.
The guards parted to allow 999 safe passage
into the facility, watching in amazement,
and once it was inside, 999’s slime parted,
releasing its contents: One very relieved
little boy.
It seemed through turning up its own opacity,
999 had given the boy safe passage through
the sun and back into the facility.
The boy was saved.
It had won.
Not long after that, there was a tearful reunion
between mother and child, and a brief flash
of hope in this dark and terrible time.
999 didn’t stop to bask, of course - It
returned to its duties, keeping up staff morale
and helping the refugees heal from
the horrors they’d seen.
In its own little way, and for a lot of people,
SCP-999 really was saving the world.
Or what was left of it, anyway.
Oh, and of course, if SCP-999 has won your
hearts just like it’s won ours, you’ll
be pleased to know that you can purchase your
own adorable, high-quality SCP-999 plushie
at scpswag.com.
Check the link in the description to get your
own.
Trust us, having a 999 to cuddle really does
make any apocalypse a whole lot easier.